on book tv
call 1-877
on c-span for pricing information or to
request a tape
christopher phillips is the founder of
the society of philosophical inquiry
next he discusses his book socrates cafe
it's the story of a discussion group he
organized for people to examine each
other's viewpoints using the socratic
method of inquiry
it's about a little over an hour and 10
minutes
hi i want to welcome you all to changing
hands bookstore i'd like to ask that you
please turn off cell phones pagers and
anything else that will be
during the reading tonight
i just want to mention a couple of
upcoming readings that we have we have a
new newsletter um that lists all of the
readings in april we have amy tan coming
thursday of this week uh noah adams on
mother's day wow and start coming may
30th which will be a benefit for free
arts for er
pre-arts for arizona
christopher phillips is a man who
believes in taking philosophy out of the
classroom and into the bookstores and
coffee shops he is on a mission to
revive the love of questions that
socrates once inspired an ancient
athlete he is the founder of the society
of the philosophical inquiry a
grassroots non-profit organization with
inquiries from all walks of life at
changing hands we consider christopher
phillips to be part of our family
last year he drew more than 80 people to
our store to begin a valley socrates
cafe and then we had him here to kick
off the tour of his reading for his book
and we had another full crowded audience
and now daily we get calls at our store
asking for christopher's return and for
the initiation of a socrates cafe at our
store we at changing hands are very
protective and honored of our family
members so please join me in welcoming
christopher phillips
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you it's great
to be back i've been on the road for
non-stop for two and a half months now
promoting my book and
most importantly of all starting
socrates cafes
it's just been amazing there are now
about
35 of these groups ongoing on a regular
basis all across the country
places like newport news virginia
charlottesville virginia
corvallis oregon austin texas salt lake
city utah
just all over the place and it's been
marvelous to be a
a catalyst to creating a kind of
community that very sadly
i felt had gone by the wayside
and that um many of us and i started
very for very selfish reasons i wanted
to meet wonderful people like you and
find a sort of be the person to kind of
start a gathering that would bring
kindred spirits together uh
like-minded in the sense that they all
wanted to
lock hearts and minds with other people
and they really wanted to
learn what other people had to say and
what their own
views were i personally find that i only
discover what my own views amount to
by engaging with other thoughtful souls
and
i had this great i call this
experimental philosophy and my
assumption was that number one people
could engage with one another and have a
dialogue in a thoughtful and yet
impassioned way without it devolving
into a knockdown drag out browbeating
sort of rhetorical confab that
i personally find very non-redemptive
though i know jerry springer disagrees
with me
so and it's it's been so pleasing
that uh
it has touched accord with people
um the group that i started in montclair
new jersey where somebody here tonight
is from who graduated from the same
place my wife and i did
base that's the very first group i
started and that was in august of 96 and
to this day
every single tuesday night without ever
missing a tuesday night
they have socrates cafe and
we were just back there was like a great
family reunion a great homecoming to go
back there and be part of it again
and they've had to move about four times
these little wonderful little cafes that
they go to they do
sadly have to close from time to time
but socrates cafe thankfully is a
movable philosophical feast
and
businesses and lots of other places are
very very open to socrates cafe into
letting these communities come in
because they recognize that it's good
for business and they recognize that
it's great for community and that people
are craving community i was so thrilled
to find that now there's a
regular socrates cafe here
in uh tempe every thursday night from
seven to nine pm at the gold bar cafe
and
and that is on mcclintock and southern
and um so that is fantastic um lindsey
mainland and and one other person is
coordinating it
that is just wonderful that is
absolutely wonderful i look forward to
coming back in may
and being a part of that
that is fantastic if anybody wants to
see where socrates cafes are now all you
have to do is link into my website at
philosopher.org
and i'm putting up a list of all the
different socrates cafes and the
different contact people
so whether you're traveling just like
you know sort of like a motel 6
directory you can just sort of see where
socrates cafe is and become a part of
that family even if it's just for a
night or so um and more and more
starting all the time and
it's so important to know that um and to
understand that socrates cafe isn't just
a place i mean it's a concept and it can
happen it can take place virtually
anywhere take place on a mountain top
can take place in a church could take
place wherever people want to get
together and inquire with other
thoughtful souls
i've done well over a thousand of these
now socrates cafe dialogues and i think
the reason that i'm continually
exhilarated is because
um
i always learn so much from the other
people i mean i really go there too i
love to pick other people's brains
because then it forces me to challenge
my own cherished assumptions and see if
there really are up to snuff or if they
may uh need some fine-tuning some
philosophical fine-tuning
and uh whenever after i have a socrates
cafe dialogue i feel like i've had about
10 cups of coffee it's uh i have so many
questions uh jocelyn and jousting in my
mind
and uh i just need to sort of try to at
least tentatively resolve them before i
can even think about closing my eyes for
the evening um how many people are here
for the i've never been to a socrates
cafe or here for the first time
okay
great how many of you all read my first
book how to build a better barbecue
[Laughter]
well that's great i'm glad to see that
there's so many new people and so now
you know that already
if you want to get together and go to
one there's one on thursday night every
single thursday night in uh at gold bar
cafes marvelous cafe um it's it's nice
my uh the first leg of my tour is this
is the very last event
this is and this was also the very first
place i started in uh january and my
wife and i are going to mexico city
tomorrow
and we're going down there for several
weeks we had um since you're new i'll
tell you that the six months preceding
my book tour that began in january we
had been in chiapas mexico where the
zapatista guerrilla uprising for
indigenous peoples rights is taking
place
and since this is sort of guerrilla
philosophy in a sense it's meant to you
know go back to where people are
wherever they are whether they're in
universities or out of universities um
this is philosophy for people from any
walk of life and for any age
um and so i was holding socrates cafes
in the plazas in mexico in chiapas
primarily first with indigenous people
who
spend 16 18 hours a day seven days a
week selling their beautiful wares in
the plazas of chiapas
and
don't make a lot of money their children
have no hope no chance of going to any
sort of formal school receiving any sort
of formal education
and um
it was interesting at first you know i
would go out in the evening when
things were pretty slow in terms of
selling their goods to tourists i
thought i would bring a thermos of hot
tea out into the plaza
and um at first it was a very small
group and i think they thought i was
rather wacky
for uh wanting to ask questions the
kinds like what is truth or what is
justice and things like that
but you know um
paolo frere wrote about the culture of
the oppressed and the culture of silence
that needs to be broken through and one
of the reasons on once they realized i
wasn't trying to sell them any bill of
goods and i really just wanted to
engage with them and and to learn from
them um
that i wasn't their teacher at least we
were all each other's teachers we were
all inquiring together
on the same playing field not that they
were all equal we all bring different
experiences and different perspectives
to the discourse but um
chiseling away at that culture of
silence um you know questioning becomes
a habit it becomes a tradition and so
the biggest thing to get overcome was
the fact that no one had ever asked them
what they thought about anything so
needless to say they had never asked
themselves what they thought about a lot
of these questions that we were i was
trying to raise
but sort of on the magic of socrates
cafe is over time as you hang in there
suddenly it's like a light switch
turning on and you can see people
thinking outside the lines and getting
really turned on to critical and
creative thinking
and when when we left uh at uh just
before my tour began was like uh
there were so many fast friendships
formed and um
i remember this one ten-year-old girl
named cecilia my wife's name
uh who hadn't said a word in any of the
gatherings and the very last evening we
talked about what is a good person and
once again true to form she didn't say a
word even though she listened with all
her being i mean she participated by
listening
she she came up to me at the end and she
hugged me and she said
whispered in my ear after the event was
formally over she says a good person is
somebody who brings hot tea out
every night and just brought tears to my
eyes and she gave me these beautiful
pulsaras these wrist bracelets that she
admitted and i've been passing them out
to people i've been meeting
uh during my tour i feel sort of like uh
loretta and doolittle lin from the movie
coal miner's daughter cecilia and i've
just been going place to place to place
to place to place uh for such a long
time but uh it's been so worthwhile
we've met so many great people um i
thought um
what would be really since there's a lot
of new people tonight i thought um
maybe i'll read the very first vignette
from my book socrates cafe because i
think that's the vignette that gives the
best sense of
who i am and what i'm all about and
hopefully will inspire you to want to
become a part of the socrates cafe here
and maybe from there even let that serve
as a springboard to start socrates cafes
wherever you want to
um
is so you know and again i found that
people
by sort of tapping into this child life
but by no means childish questioning
nature that i think we all have within
um it really gets us thinking in our own
unique ways in our own unique form that
what we say and do and think really does
matter and count i would argue
that
no time more than the present doesn't
matter when you see the sorts of things
that are swirling around us
that it's time to start taking our
communities back and time to start
weighing in again
i think this kind of foundational
community these kinds of communities of
inquiry that socrates cafe and other
types of groups can help start i think
it gets people more involved in other
aspects of community life too
and um that's really really neat this is
uh
you can tell this book is starting to
wear out i've been reading it for a long
time i'm so pleased that
my quirky little philosophical book has
now gone into a third printing so it
must be catching on at least a little
bit uh lots of nice enclaves around the
country
but let me read the first section which
is entitled socrates cafe
and then we can just sort of see what
happens after that if you have questions
or whatever you want to do
okay
is that okay if i read a section first
okay socrates cafe
i think psychiatry is the rape of the
muse
the man's outburst jolts me from my
reverie
i'm perched on a swivel stool in the
middle of about 45 people seated on
filigreed wrought iron benches and
chairs in the courtyard of an art deco
cafe in san francisco
it's a tuesday night in mid-summer and
we're about halfway through this
particular weekly gathering
and we're trying to answer the question
what is insanity
the dialogue is started out grounded in
concrete examples
which quickly begged more and more
questions
such as
was hitler insane
well was society itself insane at the
time did hitler just tap into it with
cold and calculating sanity
was jack london insane
what about edgar allan poe
and van gogh
was insanity a key to their genius
is anyone who sacrifices his health for
his art insane
or is such squandering the very essence
of sanity
is it saying to risk your life for
something that you
believe in
or for something that you don't believe
in
is a business person saying who works
all day at a job he or she hates
is the society wacky that tries to
prolong perpetually the lives of the
terminally ill
is it nutty to have thousands of nuclear
weapons poised to be launched an act
that would obliterate the planet
how can anyone be
in how can anyone be sane in this world
or is the universe itself insane
how is the concept of insanity related
to such concepts as irrationality
eccentricity
lunacy and craziness
is it possible to be sane and insane at
the same time
is it impossible not to be
is it possible to be completely sane or
to be completely insane
what are the criteria for determining
that someone or something is insane
is there really any such thing as
insanity
questions questions questions
they disturb
they provoke
they intimidate
and they exhilarate
they can make you feel a little bit like
you've at least temporarily lost your
marbles
so much so that at times i'm positive
that the ground is shaking and shifting
under our feet
but not from an earthquake
well welcome to socrates cafe
even though it's the dead of summer it's
a chilly evening
no matter the courtyard is filled
the motley group of philosophical
inquirers aging beatniks and business
people students shop workers professors
palm readers bureaucrats homeless people
among many others
are huddled in the middle of an ivy lace
garden
and in a way
the gathering slightly or even somewhat
resembles a church service
for heretics
and what connects us is a love for the
question
and a passion for challenging even our
most cherished assumptions
well all attention is now fastened on
the tall real thin man who lashed out at
psychiatrists just a moment ago
but he did so only after a psychiatrist
had said with an air of authority that
the only antidote to insanity
is psychiatric treatment
so while the psychiatrist in question
now seems a bit ruffled by the
disparaging remark about his profession
his critic is sitting stock still the
picture of calm
he has deep said blue eyes that seem to
be looking inward in a gaunt face that
reveals the faintest hint of a smile
his bright red hair is neatly combed
straight back except for one rebellious
lock dangling over his forehead
at the moment the only sound to be heard
as we look his way is the trickling
water in the gargoyle fountain
well i asked this man i say what do you
mean
how is psychiatry the rape of the muse
i have an inkling judging by the look on
his face now that he'd hoped his
statement would have shock value
now we let it pass unchallenged
not a socrates cafe
here we subscribe to the ethos that it's
not enough to have the courage of your
convictions but you should always have
the courage to have your convictions
challenged
well it takes him some time to fix his
gaze on me
at last he says choosing his words
carefully
plato spoke of a type of divine madness
which he defined as possession by the
muses
he says plato said having this madness
was indispensable to the production of
the best poetry
but psychiatrists want to modify our
behavior
they want us to be moderate people
they want to destroy our muse
another man quickly interjects at this
well i'm a psychiatric social worker
and i expect him also to take offense at
this critique of psychiatrists
but instead with a pensive half smile he
says
you know i worry a lot about the effects
the long range effects on people of
antipsychotic medications
says just psychiatrists try to cure
children with attention deficit disorder
by giving them ritalin
i think that drugs like hal doll and
zymexa and the old thorazine are
dispensed with alarming frequency to
adults because of society's desire to
control behavior
he says modern behaviors become the god
of our mental health system
and to me this is chilling
the gaunt face man asks his unexpected
ally
well don't you think it's better to be
insane
than to let them kill the artist in you
this inspires me to ask
but is it a choice between moderation
and sanity
can't we be a little insane or somewhat
insane without being completely insane
in one of plato's dialogue socrates says
that it's a common a combination of
sobriety and madness impels the soul to
philosophize
and i'm wondering if the same is true
with art
can't we temper the insanity within in a
way that enables us to be even more in
touch with our muse and so be even more
creative than we'd otherwise be able to
be
sounds pretty good huh well but then i
start to wonder if i know what i'm
talking about
you see i seem to be the last person to
know sane from insane
for a very good while now i've been on
the rather zany quest of bringing
philosophy
to the people
wherever they happen to be
and almost always i do it for free
either for free or for pittance i
facilitate philosophical discussions
which i call socrates cafe
i go to cafes and coffee houses and
diners
i go to bookstores and libraries i go to
days care centers nursery schools
elementary schools junior high and high
schools
schools for at-risk kids special needs
kids gifted kids
i go to senior centers nursing homes
assisted living residences
i go to churches hospices prison
i travel across the country
from what memphis to manhattan from
washington dc to washington state not to
mention good old tempe
to engage in philosophical dialogue but
most of uh most of all most importantly
of all to hopefully inspire others to
start their own socrates cafe in their
own neck of the woods
i pay all expenses out of my own
threadbare pockets and earn a dollar
here and there by other means
and i often ask myself am i crazy to do
this
but that's beside the point
this isn't about money
i still want you to buy my book though
hypocrite
it's a calling
and well for one thing i don't
facilitate socrates cafe to teach others
i facilitate socrates cafe so that
others can teach me
the fact is i always learn much more
from other participants than they could
ever learn from me
each gathering enables me to benefit
from the perspectives of so many others
and for another thing you might even go
so far as to say that this crazy quest
of mine has saved my sanity
well eventually in the course of this
four hour dialogue more and more hands
go up around the circle
the discussion heats up it gathers a
certain momentum
and then eventually
a bald stocky man with a fedora clenched
in one hand jumps to his feet
i can speak as an expert on this subject
of insanity he says
in his remarkable bright green eyes
dance from one participant to another
he says i've been committed to
psychiatric institutions three times
since the beginning of the year
and who are they
to classify me as insane
who are they
to classify me
i'm one of the sanest smartest people i
know
he says and he remains standing
he seems quite surprised that his
comment isn't met with shock or derision
instead he's peppered with questions
people want to know his story
it seems clear that most of them
are asking themselves well who better to
comment with some insight on insanity
than a person who's been labeled insane
in fact i'm hard-pressed to think of any
other setting in which a group of people
most of whom are complete strangers
would crave hearing more from someone
who's just said he's certifiably insane
even if as he insists he's been
misdiagnosed
and then you know what he goes on to say
one of the most memorable
and reasonable things i've ever heard in
a soft voice he says
don quixote was mad
but his madness was of a type that made
him immortal
the spanish philosopher miguel de una
muno said that don quixote's legacy was
himself
unamuno wrote that a man
a living eternal man
is worth all the theories and all the
philosophies because
in a sense he remains on this earth
and he lives among us inspiring us with
his spirit
and he says i think what that what
miguel de onomuno says
is even more true of socrates
because unlike don quixote
socrates apparently lived among us at
one time
and i think he was the epitome of a
rational person
the man pauses for a moment
his head is now bowed
and then he looks up at all of us again
and he says
socrates left us himself
he left us his unique brand of virtue
and his unique brand of wisdom
and i think he remains among us
inspiring us with his spirit
and then he sits down
we just look at this man in wonder for a
while there's a wonderful powerful
silence
eventually a statuesque woman with
purple hair is wearing a greenpeace
t-shirt asks
was socrates really all that sane
and i asked her well what do you think
well she replies when socrates was tried
and convicted
of heresy for impiety and corrupting the
youth of athens
his prosecutors hinted that if he'd keep
his mouth shut
they wouldn't put him to death
but socrates said he'd rather die than
quit asking questions
and i asked her what do you think do you
think was crazy of him to prefer death
well she says sort of sign at the same
time
socrates said that the unexamined life
wasn't worth living
so i guess for him it wasn't crazy
oh i think he was crazy
says a somewhat disheveled man in
sandals a hawaiian shirt and a battered
bowler hat that completes a picture of
sartorial strangeness
he goes on to say but socrates brand of
craziness has been the guide for
civilizations whenever they try to set
themselves on a road of sanity
socrates was the quintessential social
being
and wherever he went and engaged in
dialogue
he tried to help people be more
thoughtful and more rational
he says
he wasn't insane because his decisions
were conscious and rational choices
within his control
even his decision to end his life he
says was such a choice
but by normal societal standards he was
crazy
a good crazy
well i end this evening's discussion
very long discussion on insanity by
saying that i typically what i typically
say at the end of every socrates cafe
gathering
something to keep thinking about
and then
the participants clap
are they nuts
the discussion was intense it was
passionate it was frustrating
emotions that many times were highly
charged
the dialogue ended with many more
questions than answers
and nothing was resolved once and for
all
so why clap
i don't know but i wind up clapping too
that's from socrates cafe
anybody gonna call you
all right
you go
[Applause]
so
that's just a little vignette and i hope
that um no matter what vignette you read
you want to become part of the dialogue
and i find that no matter what question
you're
immersed in
you're always discovering further and
further answers to those questions of
questions who am i
maybe even who who might i still want to
become and how can i go about becoming
that person
at least that's what i've found so what
do you anybody got any
questions or things on their mind or
don't be shy
anybody
i do okay as you were talking i'm
thinking about how the difference
between a teacher who stands in a podium
and speaks speaks speaks to people to
impart all this grand wisdom and the
difference between a teacher who instead
of trying to teach what he believes what
she believes
instead awakens the truth within each
person that's in the room and i think
that that's what i see your socrates
cafe must do and it just thrills me to
think that you know it's not something
that we have to teach each other but
just awaken
i like you know i
i want to write that down
i could not that's so beautifully put
yeah i mean one of the reasons i took
the microphone away from there i have
been on
to 60 book tours 60 book stores so far
and i've yet to sit behind a podium um i
think it's that kind of separation that
we need to get away from
you know there's so many kinds of
teaching
so many ways to go about imparting
different ways of wisdom different
ways of world viewing and world making
and i just think it would be really
presumptuous of me to
sit up from on high
uh
and i mean let's put it this way there's
enough people out there already who are
trying to
tell people their little corner hold on
the way the truth and the light and
charges them a pretty penny for it and
and if people get things
out of it that's great but it's not my
cup of tea and i was just glad to have
discovered a a method a real method and
a real way of engaging in dialogue
that actually lends itself
to
helping each and every one of us
do no more and no less
than further articulate
and clarify and discover
our own unique world view our own unique
veltenchang our way of world viewing and
world making and that's why i do this um
you know i'm a certified school teacher
all the way from pre-k through adult
school i've got three master's degrees
and i love scholarship
but i don't like the kind of scholarship
where
there's a person here i mean i have so
many friends who
used to love philosophy but they became
so intimidated uh you know they were so
graded on their thoughts became so
discouraged about expressing themselves
freely not always there's some glaring
exceptions to that
but um i was sort of reacting to that um
and i have actually discovered that i'm
discover myself that my oath my most
original when i'm with a like-minded
group of souls who like themselves like
to engage in critical and creative
thinking
um
you know last time i looked no two
people on planet earth occupy the exact
same space
so that seems to lend itself to the view
that well we all do have slightly
different perspectives or maybe at times
dramatically different perspectives and
takes on whatever question it is that we
happen to be discussing we all have
different experiences we've all read
different things
and it's really nice to be part of a
type of dialogue that's not just a
non-sequitur confab or one person says
something somebody else nobody follows
each other up but it sort of evolves in
a very rigorous
way and yet a very spontaneous way at
the same time and that all of us in a
sense are very
exquisitely and wonderfully perplexed um
and that together maybe together we gain
a higher ground collectively and yet i
dare say at the same time each in our
own very unique way
um
and that's why to me you know when i
first started doing this you know i just
went to cafes and places but then i
thought well that's kind of elitist of
me because a lot of people can't come to
cafes um in fact when after a story
about me in the new york times had come
out i got a letter from a man in a
nursing home
he said i can't come out there he said
will you come here to the nursing home
and help us start a socrates cafe so i
did i thought well gosh why
you know why didn't i even think of that
sooner so i went to this
place in teaneck new jersey
and started and since then i've gone to
about 200 nursing homes and senior
centers
and in an unabashed act of social
engineering one of my favorite things to
do is to bring together seniors and kids
what i call younger folks and older
folks
and that is just thrilling because
you know they both in their own unique
way have been very marginalized by
society
um
you know we keep them in there but
they're so probingly honest
and they they want to ask questions they
want to ask questions to their heart's
content and they don't want people to
uh unnaturally bring their questioning
to an end and you know you bring seniors
and kids together and at first they're
like complete strangers and they leave
like long-lost friends
and it's a really marvelous thing
um to do i encourage anybody who does
socrates cafe to at least from time to
time you know
go to wherever people are or where you
think they might want to ask questions i
find people in nursing homes
thinking so hard and asking themselves
did i make the right choices did i live
the right way um
and so often and it's you know nursing
home directors are some of the most
blessed people i've ever met um
almost all of them have been receptive
to bringing socrates allowing me to
bring socrates cafe
into their um
into their uh facility
um
and they say that people who never come
to the activities who've lived there for
years and have never come come to
socrates cafe because it's not some
mindless thing where they're just
passing the time
they get to actually lock hearts and
minds with other thoughtful people and
that can make a big difference i mean i
whether you think you're going on to
another world or another life i think
there's something marvelous about
spending
your your golden years really
thoughtfully and reflectively engaging
with other wonderful people and it's
been
nice to be a catalyst it's funny my my
most difficult places to gain entree
have been libraries
and schools
i thought i'd have a great deal of
difficulty going into seniors
residences and that's been no problem
whatsoever
um
i
i want to understand that myself because
you know this really
inspires people to go back and read the
great books um one of my very best
friends on this earth uh who i met at
socrates cafe
when he first came and he didn't know
what to expect this was the group i
started five years ago in montclair new
jersey which still meets every tuesday
night
he came and had never read a word of
philosophy in his life and was so
fell in love with philosophy and
philosophical inquiry he's 72 he's a
retired
postal worker and now he's gone back to
school to get his bachelor's degree in
philosophy
so it really but he went you know to
libraries and started getting bundles of
books and started whatever whatever we'd
have a dialogue on that particular
evening well then he'd go to a library
the next day and just gather anything he
could to start reading voraciously about
it and he and i just became fast friends
and we'd get together at a diner and
just talk about
all these things but i've had librarians
lecture me
i always offer to do it completely for
free they tell me how much trouble would
be to put up flyers uh this beautiful
library that i used to live by in
burlingame california she just for two
years
just wouldn't have anything to do with
me it was it was very frustrating um
they allow musicians to come in and play
music though
i i don't quite get the tie into what uh
what the normal
purpose of a library is but i haven't
figured it out there i've been allowed
into two
two in the last um
five years
of dogged trying and i think it's um but
they've let me come in again and again
and again
and they have discovered they were just
receptive right away
and they just have discovered you know
libraries to me are
about as close as you're going to get in
america to a place where just about
anybody and everybody feels comfortable
coming because you know lots of people
even though a cafe is a public place
don't feel comfortable coming into a
cafe
the library in america is the closest
that i've come to the market to the
plaza in mexico where people who
typically don't have a lot to do with
one another
will come together and sort of rally
around whatever question we're
discussing um and it's really neat this
library where i'm going to in tacoma
park maryland very shortly
it's in this really cool area where on
one side of the street there are these
unadorned housing projects on the other
side there's these stately houses for
the well-to-do bureaucrats who work in
washington and i'll never forget this
one time we were having a discussion on
what is the question and what does it do
and this man who looks like he made many
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
was trying to formulate what he was
trying to say and then this little kid
who he and his mother had immigrated
from nigeria his mother didn't speak a
word of english but it brought his her
child there because she thought he'd get
a lot out of it
just said this very articulate and
eloquent thing about what questioning
means to him and the really rich
well-to-do man pointed himself yes
that's exactly what i wanted to say
and he didn't even realize he wasn't
even thinking about how unique such a
circumstance was but it's really
marvelous to uh
how did you draw out the people in
mexico then if they had a background
where they were
verbally questioning how did you draw
them out
very slowly i mean i went
every single night
yeah um
you know and my favorite
i thought of this too a follow-up
question i have to that is once they did
start talking are there
because of their backgrounds or their
points of view different or do you find
in traveling around
a universal thought for instance what is
truth do you have a it's always a
different answer i'm sure individually
but do you get a universal uh thinking
to that one these are fantastic
questions um
i discover
again and again and again
just how unbelievably unique people are
people who've been living together like
the indigenous people in the communities
that surround san cristobal de las casas
in chiapas mexico
how unique each one of them is and their
perspectives but i also
discover universals in particulars
like for instance we may be talking
about what is evil what is justice
or what is work
and
each person will
have
a slightly different or dramatically
different idea of what constitutes evil
or good or work or or what is a question
and what does a question do and
anything
but i'll also define that once they
start over a course of a two or three
hour dialogue
really get i you know really push them
to articulate criteria you know what
specific criteria do you use to
say that in that specific context as an
act of evil or as an act of good or that
is silence
that is my philosophy of silence
you'll find that even though
the context might differ dramatically
like one person may think it's evil to
eat animals
flesh from another person may think it's
evil not to
some um
the criteria that they
hash out and articulate are remarkably
similar if not completely identical even
though based on their religious and
spiritual beliefs where they think
things are endowed with spirit
that is what the context itself once you
get people to
once you really push them to cite
specific examples you'll see that that
differs widely and then once you get
them to hash out criteria
those are so remarkably similar but i'll
tell you one of the most
unforgettable discussions i ever had was
in chiapas it had been i'd been down
there for three months
going out there every single night at
first just a few people huddled around
me
they're there
you know i went to them you know i just
went out to the center you know after
the marine after the
marimba music in morenga
we would go out and it's always
beautiful nights and i brought tea it
was kind of an incentive
you can't philosophize about something
to drink
um
that one time
well see the thing was once they
realized that i truly
look i don't care whether you're
formally educated or have no formal
education at all you know when there's
someone coming out there who's a snake
oil salesman especially if you've been
exploited and heinously oppressed for
generation after generation or if
somebody really wants to know what you
think
and wants to engage with you i mean my
you know my mom is from a coal mining
camp in west virginia she was born and
raised in a little shack in west
virginia so
i mean i know
what it's like just from what she's told
me about what it's like to be raised in
the most oppressive circumstances
imaginable um
you know there's no greater gift that
you can give a person to start chiseling
away at that culture of silence so they
can discover that universe within their
minds
so
i wasn't cowed in the least by these shy
soft-spoken people
um
i knew that once they realized how
genuinely interested i was that
something would happen it was like magic
sort of you know this you sort of
advance together along this socratic
path of enlightenment um but one time we
were talking i wanted to bring back some
of the original questions that
so-called historical socrates supposedly
asked and
once one night i asked what is justice
and it was very interesting the woman
said
an indigenous woman and by this time it
wasn't just indigenous people the
mexicans came too and let me tell you
there's a lot of racism there they
typically don't have a lot to do with
each other but they completely forgot
about that because they were so
intrigued by the question
but the woman said here's a woman with a
baby on this thing around her back
nursing a baby two babies in tow talking
to me and she said well there's no such
we don't have the word justice in our
language
and i'm just thinking what are you
talking about justice you mean here's
people i said well you have to have the
word injustice because look at what's
happened to you he goes no we don't have
injustice too because as she explained
to me to have the word injustice
you have to have the word justice too
so i'm getting exasperated i'm thinking
but how can that be
she says well look of course we know the
spanish word for justice and injustice
of course we have been horribly
exploited and oppressed but in our
indigenous community
we don't have what we consider to be
injustice so we don't have a word or an
equivalent word for the word justice
so all we're speaking spanish because
that's that's not their native language
it's not mine either but that's the
language that we can all meet on
um and so this is how she explained it
to me she says you know there was a
meeting not too long ago where
a member of our community wanted to
remove a tree from a certain area where
his lodging is
and we met for two full days
to as a community to discuss whether he
could remove that tree or not
you know they believe things are endowed
with spirit so to do something like that
is really a
big deal and she said we either
unanimously agree to it
or we don't do it either way
but we'll talk the talk for as long as
we need to need to until everybody's on
the same page one way or the or the
other and they did they met for two full
days and they ultimately decided not to
remove the tree
um but so but nobody can leave until
they're all convinced that that's the
way to go
and at first you know i'm my western
sensibility but the whole purpose of
this type of dialogue
for me is to open myself up to new
imaginative and intellectual vistas to
sort of break out at least a little bit
more out of my own existential eggshell
so to me at first it was hard to pry me
out of my own western sensibility
because i'm thinking ah how can you ever
get anything done you know how can you
build bridges and co and super walmart
and all those other beautiful and
horrible things
and then i realized it was sort of like
this epiphany that happens quite often
at a socrates cafe that
gosh isn't that a better way
than in what is happening more and more
often in my beloved country when let's
say somebody wants to build a new super
duper walmart
or build a 16 lane highway because they
just decided 10 lanes just isn't enough
it's just not noisy enough yet
um
and then so they'll have public hearings
because they have to
and 99.9 of the thousands of people who
come out say they're opposed to it
and they go do it anyway
you know they wantedly destroy mother
nature and do something and think in you
know woefully short term ways
and i wonder i asked myself now that i
have something to compare it to now that
i've lived in another culture so
dramatically different than my own and i
ask myself which way is better
so here's a people with this thriving
and flourishing culture and heritage
that continues to exist in spite of and
because of everything that's happened
around them in chiapas mexico and here
is united states which is supposedly the
beacon of democracy
and it's really made me think about a
lot of things um you know for the first
time in 71 years mexico has a different
political party in power it's quite
fascinating um my wife and i my wife is
from mexico city
and we were both kind of dubious about
this guy he was a coca-cola executive
but it's been fascinating to see what a
deep social conscience this man has and
how committed he is to passing
getting passed in the legislature the
bill for indigenous people's rights that
the previous political party just used
as political leverage and never had any
interest whatsoever in passing so i'm
excited i'm we're going back to mexico
for three weeks tomorrow and i'm going
to hold socrates cafes in the plaza of
mexico city this time and one place i'm
going is the plaza where during the
student uprisings in mexico a few
decades ago several a number of students
were killed and we're going to go there
and
go back and look at some of these
questions so mexico is now a second home
to me
um
or not even a second home it's another
home and over the summer we're going
back to chiapas and continue the work
there because my goal is of course not
to be the chris phillips show it's to
inspire other people to carry the torch
you know with people with low
self-esteem and people who've existed in
a culture of silence
this doesn't happen overnight it takes a
long time to get them to the point where
they feel comfortable even thinking
about facilitating but that's the point
you know there's enough
it's funny you know the more things
change the more they stay the same i
mean there's enough
what i call sophists out there right now
there's enough people who want to create
another needless dependency and want to
be the philosopher or the thinker and
you the peons down here
um i'm just i reject that um i think
it's demeaning and belittling and
i think people once people are in the
right setting
i have found again and again and again
that the so-called common man and common
woman is uncommonly perceptive it's just
being in the right setting and having
a method an undergirding method that is
sort of allows people to bring out that
unique side of them it just lends itself
to it um and i'm and i try to make a
really strong case for that in my book
um and if you know there's a guide on my
website that you can download on my it's
philosopher.org and it's you about how
to start and how to facilitate a
socrates cafe and and what i've
discovered to my joy is that
anybody who's read my book and has this
guide and nuts and bolts god and how
facilitate can easily start a socrates
cafe wherever they want to
it's just been great can i tell you one
little story um
you know it's funny when i started i
mean i had the most modest of ambitions
when i started socrates cafe
i just i couldn't care when two people
came i was
excited out of my mind
um i had no plans to write a book no
plans to start a non-profit group i just
wanted at a time when i felt like
society was becoming so
self-absorbed and people were becoming
such islands and to themselves that
it would be nice to
offer an alternative and i certainly am
not the first person on this planet
who's lived on a shoestring budget
unless to take a sublime risk to have an
assumption to have a hypothesis that if
you start something people will come
and people will other people will buy
into it um
with the idea of creating a
a kind of empathetic community of
critical creative thinkers um so i
started at this little sliver of a cafe
in new jersey
and the first time lo and behold about
25 people came just very diverse very
wonderfully imaginative and thoughtful
and critical thinkers
the second time 30 people came
and i was just really on my high horse
because so many people even people who
were very supportive of me you could
tell he didn't think it would work
um and so the third time you know i
asked for a stool to sit on because you
know the the crowd was out there
and nobody came
and it was so fun you know i was just
feeling so sorry for myself no um you
know i talk about everyone else being
self-absorbed and self-pitying well i
had them all beat that night
um and then about 10 minutes after the
dialogue was supposed to start
somebody just timothy came in and looked
in and said is this the socrates cafe
and before she could even think of
turning back around hightailing it out
of there i grabbed her and we sat down
uh and i finally teased out of her the
question that she wanted to talk about
took a while and she wanted to talk
about what is love
and we ended up talking for
several hours on this question and i had
trouble focusing on the question from
time to time because she was so
mesmerizing in so many different ways
but um
that person's my wife now
so cece stand up this is my wife cecilia
so
obviously numbers don't matter too much
well one it was really nice that one
person came
but um after that
30 people came the next night 50 people
crammed to this tiny cafe the next night
and ever since then they've never it's
been between 20 and 50 people every
single tuesday night just suddenly
something happened
um
and it's just been lovely i think
once i did decide to write a book
after getting my 200th rejection slip
from philanthropic groups
they just all said oh chris this is such
a beautiful thing but
we have other priorities or the hearst
foundation i think wins the catch-22
award they said oh this is so beautiful
but it's we don't support groups that
small
i'm thinking well how do you get bigger
if you you know we don't we're living
out of our suitcases we don't have a
center a headquarters we the only reason
we were able to go on this tour and do
what we're doing is by putting our
belongings in storage in scottsdale um
but it's just been quite but out of
sheer despair
i you know i kept a journal of all my
dialogues and
um once i yeah we'd gone tens of
thousands of dollars in debt
gallivanting all over the place and once
i realized the philanthropic groups
weren't gonna join the parade
um ceci said well you know chris you are
a writer you've been making your living
as a writer for years
maybe you should write a book
um but i said well i don't want to do
that i want to engage with people she
goes well writing is a way of engaging
it's a way of thinking through
a lot of the dialogues that you've
you've held and thinking you know the
whole wonderful thing about once
thinking socratically becomes a habit
once you do sit down and write a book
you may think that you're going to take
a certain direction but once you start
reacting to all these things
it takes you start discovering things
again you start going in all these new
directions you would have never
discovered if you hadn't started that
path
of socratic questioning so i've tried to
take some of my riches dialogues my most
memorable dialogues and not simply
regurgitate them in some mirror image
way but to really think reflectively and
react to a lot of the wonderful things
people said but also
to bring into the dialogues a lot of
these wonderful rich thinkers from
across the divides from across the great
scholarly disciplines
thinkers both past and present and to
bring them into the equation and show
people how they've weighed into these
wonderful questions that we've had
weighed into during socrates cafe
um and then to react to their thinking
because the purpose is that i believe
that we are all our own best autonomous
critical thinkers
and i don't care how
flush a person is with academic
pedigrees um i don't care how
intellectual somebody is
you have every right
uh and i think it's almost your duty to
react critically and thoughtfully to
what anybody says to you
um because you know we're humans and
last time i checked
most people even no matter how brilliant
their thinking is
there's usually flaws wonderful
delightful flaws that you can then carry
forward on your own
um and that's you know the joy of the
novel and the unfamiliar and the uns
expected is to me what
makes us so fruitful and makes it so
worthwhile week in and week out
once you realize that even the most
wonderfully brilliant
people
people call geniuses for good reason
still you can actually find
things in their thinking that pride you
to maybe think further than they did
as long as once people get
away from that sort of emperor's new
clothes jargon
and just talk in plain english and
explain to you what their thinking
amounts to then you can react to it
that's why i love the scientists the
great cosmologists who write in plain
english and explain the rich concepts
because i you know i talk about one of
the my most memorable discussions that i
talk about in my book is called why is
what
we start talking into what is substance
and is there such thing as this holy
grail of substance the ultimate simple
or is there any such thing as a simple
and if so what is it is it just a word
and a definition or is it something with
powers and functions and properties that
may not be simple at all um
so it's uh hopefully a lot of fun
who else
who's gonna start going to socrates cafe
on thursday nights anybody been inspired
to
are there any in central games well
there um
is matthias here there is a there's a
guy named matthias who um had started
the one here at the bookstore who is
going to start one in um
in northern north central phoenix
um
we have a mailing list and if you want
to be on our mailing list we can shoot
you an email
to let you know
when that's going to start or something
like that um
there isn't one yet but i certainly hope
that there will be one soon
with you it would be a wonderful thing
[Laughter]
how many are there
[Music]
um i think at cafe cafes and bookstores
i think there's about 35
and there's a number that happen at
nursing homes
and libraries uh usually they have the
ones at cafes and coffee houses usually
meet twice to twice a month to every
single week and the ones in nursing
homes tend to meet about once a month
there's there has been one
in this bookstore and right at the gold
bar cafe just right up the road on
mcclintock at southern there's one that
meets every single thursday night
um it's from seven to nine
saw the gold bar gold bar not a great
name is there one in carlsbad california
by any chance i don't believe there is
why
well because i'm up there all summer and
uh
let's come up and start one up there
well i'll tell you what where's carlsbad
exactly it's about 30 miles
from san diego
oh wow i was just down there
yeah well you know what i tell people is
if they will start one on their own i
will come and be a guest facilitator and
then i can help them troubleshoot um
i have found it actually more fruitful
in many ways if i'm not the one that
initiates it
but that if they um read read my book
and read the facilitator's guide and
start and after it's going for a few
months um
then it's then i find it's most fruitful
if i come because then they've you know
it takes a while to get your feet um if
you're used to chris phillips from the
very beginning
i don't know i i just have found again
and again and again that it's better uh
people start their own group
that way they're not looking to me to
start it and looking to me as the person
that can
has to be there to start it
well and but also they you know i don't
want them to think that um chris needs
to be there for this to start it doesn't
um there's this wonderful guy
in davis california his name scott
mccord and he learned about what i was
doing several years ago
asked me if i'd come started and i said
the same thing i'm just saying to you
right now so why don't you start one
so about one out of 20 people actually
take me on my word
and they start they start one you know i
get hundreds of inquiries all the time
but so one out of 20 is actually good
and he did he put up flyers everywhere
and
about five months after he started it i
came
and he said gosh i'm so glad you came
now because i i can see where i've sort
of been
maybe not facilitating as well as i
could have or the kinds of questions you
ask um
and it's been a flourishing group for
several years now um
and so again and again and again that's
happening um it's really interesting you
know
socrates cafes don't just flourish in
big places in big cities but they tend
to also flourish
in smaller communities where maybe
there's not a lot of choices and not a
lot not an embarrassment of choices in
terms of places to go or maybe there are
a lot of activities but maybe not a lot
of
gatherings that um
bring together thoughtful people where
they really are encouraged to inquire
together where diverse perspectives
doesn't in any way mean that it's going
to suddenly become a
rhetorical clash where people can be
very diverse in their views but are
thoughtful and respectful enough to
want to also find out what others really
and truly think
so places you know again it's been
surprising places like newport news
virginia in austin texas salt lake city
places where i wouldn't have thought
necessarily
what this would have caught on it's
caught on like wildfire um but i think a
lot of it's because maybe there's all
these thoughtful people that have just
been looking for a place to go and they
just needed one person in their
community
to be a catalyst
and you know the thing is to be a
coordinator of socrates cafe doesn't
take a lot of time it may take an hour a
month you just have to make you don't
have to come every time you just have to
make sure there's somebody there that
you have a place to go
um and it can be just be a wonderful
thing and you know this is a very
transient society and people do move on
um
but whether you know you still left that
socrates cafe there for the next people
you know because i've lived in many
places for one year but in one intensive
year or even six intensive months like
in chiapas you can leave something
behind that will um you've sort of
planted a seed that people really find a
value and that they will carry on
themselves um because you're this isn't
about beginning and ending with chris
phillips you know once you start on that
philosophical pursuit once you start on
that wonderful path that's sort of
shaped like a question mark
you don't
want me you don't need me and i find
that absolutely wonderful
i love coming back to the montclair
group i started five years ago
and there's so many different people
there now and people i haven't
met until i get there there's usually a
core group of about 15 folks that were
there from the very beginning way back
when
um
but it's it's funny in a certain sense
um
it's not my group anymore but in another
sense it's like a always like a
homecoming
so there's sort of those contradictory
things and that's the nice thing about
socrates cafe i think
so
i do hope that some of y'all really
think about approaching a librarian
don't let my experiences cow you i know
believe me there's always wonderful
exceptions to the rule this wonderful
life
you and me both let's see again you know
you you test these things i mean my
that's just my experience so far and
heaven knows i could go out tomorrow and
there might be 10 librarians that i'll
say yes
and i think more and more probably
become more receptive all the time
what about west virginia
no i'm going to um
warren ohio i'm going to cleveland ohio
um in west virginia i haven't been and i
would like to go to west virginia simply
because
you know that's the call where my mom
was born in a coal mining camp she was
born in a little place called tams west
virginia
and it's a little anybody familiar with
beckley west virginia
okay
what a great name athens
um well yeah well tams is much much
smaller but tams was founded by a coal
baron and his name was major tams and
there's a section in my book called no
place like home or where i'm at a senior
senior residence we explore the concept
of home and i tell them quite a bit
about my mom
um but you know it's it was this
you
ceci and i went there right before my
tour began and you know the church is
still there the canteen you can still
find scrip
um it was kind of an enlightened colbert
he had a library and that's where my mom
snuck into to discover the world of
reading
but i would like to go back to that area
even though tams is a ghost town now the
structures are still there
but you know i would like to go into
appalachia quite a bit and and get some
of this i just moved here six months ago
from west virginia
yes
20 miles to a grocery store in athens
you know compared to
20 feet yeah
but uh the town of athens would love
this
well i've been to athens i would i would
really
yeah is there a bookstore there i can
i'll have one red light hey
that's the red light district
okay no library no library wow
yeah i would i would love to go oh i
want to tell you um
so if anybody who wants a facilitator's
guide my publisher norton was
fabulous enough to print out the guide
so you can also get one here
they also make very nice coasters
usually you know enough room for two
coffee cups
and then
august 15 my children's book the
philosophers club is coming out and that
is being published by 10 speed press of
berkeley california they publish books
like what color is your parachute and
cool stuff like that this wonderful
woman illustrated it who's done a lot of
native american children stories
illustrations for that there's going to
be a teacher's guide
that goes along with that but it's a
guide for any adult who believes there's
so much to be learned from engaging with
children
it opens up great pathways of
communicating with kids it's not a
didactic way of teaching it's a way of
once kids get hold of this method
themselves you can inquire together
and learn
i dare say much more from the kids and
then they'll learn from you
that's why i do this
i actually decided not to be a teacher
even though i think it's an immensely
valuable profession i wanted to
be chris and have a club and be a
philosopher along with the other kids
um
there's a link link to my website um
national public radios all things
considered did a feature about my
labor of love philosophizing for years
with the children at an elementary
school in the mission district of uh
uh san francisco and again you know
these kids may not have a keen grasp of
those traditional 3rs but their grasp of
that fourth are
reasoning
is exhilarating and astounding and it
really inspires them to go back and
learn the three r's once they really
have opened up their minds
so i hope some of you might be
interested in the children's book once
it comes out where does that get
squashed at one point i know when i
started going to the socrates club and i
would tell people
they would they would look at me and say
that's fun for you
and i'm like how is that not fun where
did because i do believe that children
all have that where does it you know
what
where does that get squashed now see i
love that because i was in chico
california last week and the question we
asked that the group is all we had a
regular bonafide socrates cafe after the
signing and reading was
how is it that our childlike
uh critical thinking ability
gets turned off how is it that we get
trained to no longer think critically
and i think another way of saying that
is where does that get squashed i think
it's much more eloquently
eloquent way of putting it because it is
squashed i mean it's not just left that
somebody stepped on it i mean that's
what it feels like in these people that
i interact with that
all right it's missing wow however it's
not squashed with you and it's not
squashed with everybody who meets
thursday night
so the question that we challenged
immediately was is it squashed and so
what we found it was with certain people
it had been
but with others it hadn't
um maybe it had been dormant
maybe there just hadn't been the right
setting the right spark
but look socrates cafe much as i wish it
were otherwise
it ain't for everybody um what is
um but it is for a lot more people that
i've i might have thought it was for and
well that's not true because i'm very
optimistic and i always felt it was
for many more people than others did
even people who were so sympathetic to
what i was doing you could tell they
didn't think would work
beloved professors who thought that
people outside of the academic bubble
were simply were not capable of this
kind of thinking not only are they
capable of it but i dare say they're
much better at it than
most you know academics who not aren't
necessarily brought up in a tradition of
critical and creative thinking now
there's some wonderful beautiful
exceptions to that
um
but i have found again and again and
again that there are people like you
whose child like nature not only has not
been squashed but they've been
cultivating their garden their mental
garden their spiritual garden um and
they were just looking maybe for a
setting where they could meet other
other like-minded you know kindred
spirits um
but then we examined the concept of
creative thinking what in the world is
that
how do we know it when we see it is it
just anything goes
this one woman brought up this brilliant
insight she says well you know
i have found that as i get older and as
i accumulate more and more experiences
my way of thinking creatively changes
my process of thinking creatively
changes i have such so much more to
assimilate
um to assess
before i can sort of go far afield again
with my thinking
she says i don't she says for me i was
thankful that it wasn't squash for me it
was never squashed because i had a mom
who whenever i asked her why is the sky
blue or why is there a sky or
why are there questions my mom said
would always say first well why do you
think
or and she never said oh just enough
already just shut up and put a lid on
never and i i bet you there's a lot of
people here how many of you have never
had your question in nature squashed
lots of people how many of you feel like
you have had it squashed
i'm sorry to use this technical jargon
it's just uh i get carried away
sometimes
how many of you would like to unsquash
it
[Music]
well you know that's again that is what
socrates cafe is for it's to unsquash it
and to re-tap into it you know once in a
blue moon somebody will come to a
socrates cafe
and they will you can tell they sort of
sit back like this their arms are folded
and they're very defensive they'll go
wait a second
you're not telling us what the answer is
you know they came unfortunately from a
school tradition or whatever
where they were raised to believe that
some higher upper is supposed to tell
you what the answer is they get very
upset
um that's not what socrates cafe is all
about of course you do arrive at truths
it's not meant to give you a foundation
of quicksand i dare say it gives you a
firmer foundation
by questioning and challenging your
assumptions in a safe haven um
so it just all depends um
i wish um some people say once in a blue
moon
gosh you know there's no universal
agreement we all seem to be
um we all seem to have our own ideas on
whatever the question is we all whether
we're talking about what is silence we
all seem to have our own philosophy of
silence whether we're talking about what
is a question what does a question do
and what what do we do to it and what
does it do to us
we all have our own different
philosophies
now so
that's true
but um i think there's enough settings
where people bring things to artificial
closure isn't it nice to have one
setting where
it's considered a success if there's
more questions at the end than there are
at the outset and i and and i again i
dare say that if let's say that next
time you go to a con a group where you
do have to achieve consensus well maybe
you'll be much more open to other
perspectives than you otherwise would
have been by having attended hopefully
on a regular basis the socrates cafe
because it does by being more open
to other views to other world views and
ways of world making even if you leave
more entrenched in your own perspective
than ever at the end
it does it opens you up and um
society needs that right now you have
people just uh practicing both random
and intentional acts of rudeness
wherever wherever they go
um
and and we need to
react to that we need to you know all
these things as the great john dewey
wrote about our habits and even the most
intractable habit
uh
while it's hard to break
they can be broken um you know we can
espinoza taught us we can break out of
this bondage and how do you do that well
first you have to ask yourself questions
you know
what are what do i consider a bad habit
um is resentment a bad habit is fear a
bad habit is it a prison and if so how
can i break out of it can you imagine a
different person that you'd like to be
you know it's all sort of catechizing
yourself with questions
that lead to new vistas um that's how
i'm doing what i'm doing now
instead of engaging those past dwelling
seductive questions oh why didn't i do
this why didn't i do that
i started saying well what if i did this
what would i how do i envision my life
would be
um i was a very successful writer made
very good money and i threw it all away
to do what i'm doing now um to join that
tradition of people who
you know had a saw problem in society
and they wanted to dig into their patch
of the earth
um so you know you ask yourself those
questions if not now when and if not me
who
um
and you know you're not alone you know
these there's been people like that
always and they don't do it for
publicity they do it because um
you want to leave the world behind
hopefully in a in a better
place in a better situation a better
circumstance and it's great because once
you get people together you realize that
others have that vision too
there's this wonderful tension
as your vision
engages with others
i wouldn't want my vision alone to win
the day i like it when when others have
these other competing vision visions
also based on very articulate creative
imaginative visionary thinking
so
we couldn't have a conversation if there
weren't matrices of agreement but it's
those areas of wonderful blissful
sublime errors of disagreement that i
that is the reason that i can never go
to sleep immediately after socrates cafe
um you know i have to unsquash all that
you know well it seems to me like we're
all constantly sort of breaking out of
our self-imposed prisons you know from
20 to 30 i thought i can't go back to
college it's too late
i started asking myself certain
questions lo and behold by the time i
was 36 i had three master's degrees
you know so it was it it's a matter of
asking questions in the right way um and
once it becomes a habit
a way of life
it um it's so freeing and so liberating
not questioning for questions saying oh
let's think up some more questions no
it's questioning as a way of
advancement as a human being to become
advancement as a group as a community as
a society as a universe you know we're
all on this we're all survivors we're
all in this together
so uh let's get together and talk
yeah
all right well thank you so much for
coming tonight thank you
and go to socrates cafe thursday night
just two nights from now i'll be back in
town in may the first week in may and
i'm going i'll be there will y'all
invite me to facilitate can i do that
yeah
christopher phillips is the founder of
the society of philosophical inquiry
and author of socrates cafe
it's published by w w norton and company
for more information visit their website
at www.norton.com
[Music]
48 hours of non-fiction books on tv
you're watching book tv
on c-span 2.
next jack sypes professor of german at
the university of minnesota discusses
his fourth work on books for
[Music]
reading and philosophy was the topic of
this panel from the 11th annual virginia
festival of the book in charlottesville
it's just over one hour
then the investigated life arguments for
literature and philosophy
put on by the virginia book festival
which is run by the virginia foundation
for the humanities
uh it's an event which as you know uh
sponsors literacy and has school events
as well as events like this one
we want to thank the many hundreds of
volunteers who make the event possible
and you can help the event by
filling out the survey form and giving
it to one of the volunteers
at the conclusion of the
session
if you want to support the
virginia book festival in more
substantial ways you can also talk to
the information person at the
information desk at the omni hotel
um
our sub sub question is reading and
raising questions to improve your life
with david kirby and christopher
phillips
um
none of the books of these authors i
think would be found in the
self-improvement uh shelves of barnes
and noble
david kirby is a is the uh robert
o'norton
robert o'laughton distinguished
professor of english at
florida state university he's the author
of what is a book
and is a poet
as well
his collection bahaha was
chosen for the lsu press's southern
messenger poet series
david is a person of wit which he
reminds us in his book in passing is a
word which has two rather closely
related meanings
um
and uh he exemplifies both of them i
must say i can't resist reading you a
sentence from from the book um in which
he launches an article on on the
american novel and its themes in history
the american novel in all its variety
does not reflect american life so much
as it refracts it concentrating the
diffuse light of daily existence into
the concentrated radiance of art
anybody can write a sentence like that
certainly deserves to be read
our other participant is christopher
phillips he may be known to you as uh
some of you as the
originator of the socrates cafes which
have spread around the world
he's the founder of the society for
philosophical inquiry and author of six
questions of socrates socrates cafe and
philosophers club he and his wife
chatelia have estab helped establish
globally over 250 socrates cafe dialogue
groups
uh the uh what you get in the six
questions which is the book we have
available for you
um is a series of discussions on
socratic questions
um around the world and in
many unlikely places not only from the
uh greek at the agora and athens
but
japan
seoul
square in mexico city
inmates and a penal institution mentally
handicapped people he conducts his
discussions with
a wide variety of people who are not
philosophy graduate students
and yet they have interesting things to
say about rather deep philosophical
questions
anyway our format will be that each of
our speakers will speak for about 10
minutes and then we'll open it up to
questions from you
so we'll begin with david kirby
yeah i lost the coin toss so i'll start
off thank you all so much for um coming
and uh
correct me if i'm wrong maybe you have
some information that i don't have but
uh
i don't think we listen to each other in
this country the way we used to so i'm
gonna talk to you for a few minutes
about what i call the lost art of of
listening my wife and i spent last fall
in florence i was teaching at the fsu
study center there before we left our
render asked if i wanted her to forward
mail i said most of our bills were paid
electronically so if you see anything it
looks personal send that along and see
you later throw away the junk mail and
the catalogs and
and then i ran back and said oh oh oh
send the new yorkers you know i can't
imagine life without the new yorker and
i'm so glad i did because i was lying in
bed in florence one night
and i read this in a profile of the
playwright michael frain who wrote the
play
copenhagen frane said the german
playwright friedrich hable said that in
a good play everyone is right and
fraying goes on i don't suppose he meant
you had to morally approve everyone but
i take it he meant that if the
playwright is taking sides it's not very
interesting because in life it's not
like that there's no directorial figure
no writer no god figure saying this
guy's right and this guy's wrong uh and
if you remember copenhagen is a play
about the meaning of werner heisenberg
and niels bohr and it's a play in which
everyone is right
so if a play is like life in that sense
then maybe life is like a play or a
conversation when mortimer adler and
robert hitchens developed their great
books of the western world series they
spoke of the great conversation a
dialogue between canonical authors which
spans centuries
but i think the great conversation goes
beyond that i think that to truly talk
you have to truly listen and not just to
so-called wise people
but to all people so i'm going to read
you a
two-page excerpt from the first essay in
what is a book
all that summer i went to a local
housing project every wednesday
afternoon to read to a group of children
with one or two exceptions i never met
the moms and dads the children seemed to
run the place i'd park my car and start
walking toward the rec room with my
books
and someone usually one of the carter
brothers would shout story man and the
children would come running
i'd find a seat the little ones would
pile into my lap the others would
arrange themselves behind me and we'd
start
i read to those children every wednesday
because i had seen a notice in the paper
calling for literacy volunteers
mainly though i was there because i
missed reading to my own children who
were too old for it
i love children's books but i've always
found that reading them silently and
alone is a little like reading a play
instead of watching it or more to the
point acting in it
at his insistence i read to my older son
will till he was nearly 15. and when he
sat in my lap his legs stretching out
beyond mine and his arms hanging nearly
to the floor it was like cradling a cult
and not coincidentally i know some of
you know the book one of my favorite
scenes in children's uh literature
occurs in william steig sylvester in the
magic pebble which is about a a donkey
sylvester who is uh captured in a magic
spell and then he's restored to his
ecstatic
parents and he drapes himself across
their laps with his with his legs
sprawling
will's younger brother ian ended his
nightly sessions earlier when he was
around 12 but he participated in the
more aggressively as long as they
continued
ian did not like going to school at
first
at that time i was reading him fairy
tales though after a while it got to the
point where he only wanted to hear one
story the story of thumbling
a stump fumbling you'll remember is the
child of a poor peasant who says to his
wife how sad it is we have no children
with us all is so quiet and in other
houses it is noisy and lively and his
wife size and says yes
even if we had only one and even if it
were only as big as my thumb i would
still be quite satisfied and we would
love it with all our hearts
sure enough she gives birth to a child
and
equally surely he's born small and he
stays that way
but size is no obstacle as you know to
someone with as much pluck as thumbling
and he has all sorts of adventures he
even makes a lot of money for his
parents
for as the story tells us
fumbling is quote a wise and nimble
creature and everything he did
turned out well
now not only did this become ian's
favorite story but when i got to his
favorite line he'd say
read that again
and i'd say thumbling was a wise and
nimble creature and everything he did
turned out well and ian would suck his
thumb and smile and look off dreamily
and i could tell he was thinking of the
many benefits of being wise and nimble
and all the fun a wise and nimble person
might have and all the rewards he'd get
and before long ian decided that school
wasn't such a bad place after all it was
a good venue for the practice of wisdom
and nimbleness it was a place where with
a little luck things might even turn out
well
now these were not necessarily conscious
thoughts that ian had and there's
certainly never ones he expressed to me
his relation to thumbling was simply a
matter of asking for the story over and
over and listening to it and taking what
lessons from it that he could and
gradually finding that school wasn't
such a bad place after all
children almost never say why they like
or dislike a particular book partly i
suspect because they don't have the
vocabulary to articulate their deep
reasons and partly because in many cases
they would be embarrassed to say why
in this marvelous book the uses of
enchantment bruno bettelheim defends
traditional fairy tales and bethlehem's
book is controversial because many of
the traditional tales he defends aren't
politically correct
but the fundamental advice he gives
parents is still sound as i learned from
my experience with ian read story after
story to your child and let your child
pick his or her favorite it will be the
right choice even if the child can't or
won't say why
the children i read to in that housing
project also had their favorites it's
something of a common place to note that
children prefer classics to contemporary
stories and i saw some evidence of that
snow white and cinderella were favorites
among the girls who had not heard about
feminism and were still looking forward
to the arrival of the handsome prince
the boys were not especially interested
in handsomeness the carter brothers
asked for beauty and the beast
repeatedly and would echo the beast in
deep transylvanian voices when he asked
beauty do you think i am very ugly
all my wednesday children were beautiful
in the sense that their faces were open
radiant unclouded the carter brothers
were beyond that with their soft
lustrous skin and big toothed smiles
they were positively seraphic but as
they thought about that beast and how
ugly he was
and how he both despised his ugliness
and at the same time reveled in it they
crossed their eyes and left their
tongues lol out of their mouths and they
tried to be as repulsive as possible
in general though i noticed that the
children liked stories that involved
secrets like mari syndacks where the
wild things are and in the night kitchen
they liked peter pan these tales of
transformation and revolt against adult
norms were to my children as halloween
is to a regular school day their
absolute favorite and the one book i was
asked to bring back with me every time
was malcolm bird's the school in murky
wood in which a group of monster
children and their monster teacher break
into a school every night and they dump
pencil shavings on the floor and they
scroll all over the wall with chalk and
spill milk and they act sloppy and
stupid and they mess the school up and
then just before dawn they clean it up
it's it's just perfect when they when
they leave it so that the regular
students and teachers don't even notice
that anyone has been there and it drove
my children mad with joy to think that
monsters might have been in their
classrooms at barnes elementary the
night before and had slouched in their
desks and scrawled gibberish on the
board and dumped pencil shavings on the
floor and then left without a trace so
that no one knew they had been there
except the monsters and now the children
themselves
there was a secret bond between the
imaginary monsters and the real children
and neither side would tell
conversely a book they didn't like very
much was one called willie's not the
hugging kind which is the story of a
tough little guy who learns it's okay to
show your feelings after all
it was not a book that excited me
particularly but it was one of the few i
could find that had african-american
characters in it and i didn't think it
right to restrict my children to a 100
percent snow white diet
as it turned out my wednesday children
were more colorblind than i was so in
the end willie and his feel-good family
lost out to princesses and fairies and
monsters and by the way the monsters for
what it's worth turned it out to be
either various combinations of yellows
or greens or purples or also completely
with covered with hair you couldn't tell
what color their skin was so in the in
the rest of uh of uh what is a book i
talk about what college students like
what professors like to read what the
general public likes to read and i use a
lot of freud and a lot of theory and
those kinds of things but it comes back
it comes back to the same point that
people like what they like
and what they like usually has a secret
at its heart and i learned that from
listening to little kids
[Applause]
chris my turn okay well it's wonderful
to be back
in charlottesville where there's one of
our longest-running socrates cafes
coordinated by ken who's here
and also this is um
where i attended my first year of
college as an electrical engineering
student
as i was telling george before i decided
well i'm good at it but i hate it
so i hadn't read my book of chris
phillips very well yet but i transferred
to william mary and gravitated to
political philosophy and uh
some sort of career was born i didn't
know it at the time
my wife cecilia who's here my
co-founder of our non-profit group and
partner and everything
and i live in chiapas mexico and that's
where the zapatista movement for
indigenous peoples rights is taking
place
and in chiapas we have an ongoing
project with children who
sell their beautiful hand woven goods in
the fabric uh that are hand woven goods
in the plazas of chiapas and especially
san cristobal
these are children who can't read
children who have no
formal identity no birth certificate
nothing
and so
we sort of take a different approach
to
trying to inspire them
to become their own best storytellers
to
share their own stories with us at the
more than 300 socrates cafe groups that
we have now around the world i think we
take a different approach
to
reading in a sense but yet it still
seems to lead to the same goal as anyone
who wants to help people become
more adept and astute
and active readers and discoverers
and what we do is we try to
allow them to
be storytellers themselves to sort of
use the life of reason
to support what their particular and
unique story is and i think one of the
problems around the world
is that we don't take enough time to
listen to people's stories
and i think what the world needs now and
as david alluded to is uh great
listening skills empathetic listening
i wish colleges they offer classes in
rhetoric and argument and debate but
they don't offer classes that i know of
in listening 101
and how are we ever going to become
great storytellers if we don't take the
time to listen to other people's stories
so that's a big thrust of what we do in
our recent travels around the world i
i've always i love the world of
scholarship and the world of reading but
how do i know what i really like to read
or might like to read
unless i leave myself open and
vulnerable to widely different
experiences and cultures so that people
can suggest things to me that i
otherwise wouldn't be privy to
i just returned not long ago from soweto
south africa during their 10th
celebration of
freedom from apartheid and i was
as a result of locking hearts and minds
and listening to the stories of people
there
it opened me up to new possibilities of
stories i might want to know they
suggested philosophers to me that i
otherwise would not have known this
wonderful philosopher of culture who
actually graduated from harvard but is
is from ghana is kwame gyekye who's a
fabulous philosopher of culture
we were in hiroshima japan recently and
held a dialogue a spontaneous dialogue
in the peace park and there i was
introduced to some of the great
educational
philosophers such as
tsunasiburu makiguchi and also the
wonderful feminist philosopher haruka
okano
sure
my tidewater accent gets the best of me
sometime
but again it introduces me to new
possibilities it's almost like which
came first reading or first hearing
other people's stories and what i try to
do is
put myself in situations where i learn a
lot about new cultures which in turn
serves as a springboard for my own
curiosity
to learn more and dive into people's
cultures that are seemingly different
from my own and then you find they're
all these wonderful thinkers of their
own who transcend the ages and the
disciplines and are rather timeless in
the sense that they ask themselves the
same pressing questions that we ask
ourselves everywhere who am i who can i
be where is our society going where
should it be going
i'd like to
read to you just a small section of a
dialogue i held
just to give you a sense of what i'm
talking about it's just a just about two
pages
and i'll sort of
talk just a little bit more after that
and the first participant in this
dialogue says
we should seek knowledge talk knowledge
live knowledge
and
the soft-spoken sophomore whose name is
chitra who's majoring in biophysics is
dressed in traditional islamic guard
garb and she goes on to say the very
first verse or surah of the quran
exhorts us read
it tells you to seek knowledge to the
far reaches of the universe in the name
of the lord
and she says it's a pity that even many
muslims don't understand that the quran
holds in the highest esteem all the
scholarly disciplines because they are
seeking disciplines that can provide
paths to a more direct relationship with
god
and i'm i'm gathered with 15 students at
a student university cafe in
massachusetts and all these students
came to the united states from iran
and another one named ursia who's a
doctoral candidate in microbiology
and also an accomplished pianist says
well the prophet muhammad tells us to
think deeply about life in the universe
and to use our minds to reach the truth
and he urges muslim scientists and
scholars to inquire with all of humanity
to cross-pollinate knowledge
all knowledge she says is from god so
god wants us to know all we can to read
all we can and in doing so we learn more
about god and we know god more
intimately
and so i ask so all knowledge emanates
from god
and saeed who's a double major in
political science and applied ethics
says all true knowledge emanates from
god
and he says true knowledge is that which
makes you better and wiser bringing you
and your universe into greater harmony
with one another
he says anything you learn that doesn't
accomplish this as false knowledge
because it distances you from god and
creates false discord
lately a religion in history double
major says i came to the u.s like almost
everyone here speaking with you now did
from tehran
she says this is the first time in my
life i've been allowed to carry out in
the open god's mandate to seek out
knowledge
says you can't do that in iran
especially not as a woman but not as a
man either
because of the conservative leadership
here in the united states she says i'm
drinking up knowledge not just by
studying not just by reading but
conversing till the wee hours with
people who've come here from all around
the u.s and around the globe
i become a better muslim by doing this
the noble islamic traditions of inquiry
of dialogue are prohibited in iran here
at last i can follow the prophet's
injunction to become a noble knower
and i say i'm not clear on how noble
knowing translates into being able to
act practically in the world
to lead to greater harmony she says well
true knowledge now what we call noble
knowing is brings you to know god more
intimately
by knowing better how to carry out his
mandate which create harmonious and just
world community
she says but when a scholar tries to
fulfill this god-given role in iran
she's jailed or worse
iranian leaders know that the truths of
scholar would impart would lead to a
real jihad or holy war an upheaval in
society that would oust them and lead to
genuine
umas
which is their work arabic for world
civilized community based on social and
economic justice
she says islamic societies were intended
to be laboratories of scholarship
activism and experimentalism and muslims
were meant to be at the forefront of
revolutionary ways of living and the
jihad of
extremists is not true jihad they wanted
dark ages where everyone lives in fear
and ignorance where no one can read what
they want so people would do their
bidding
chitra the first to speak says true
jihad begins from within you go to war
with yourself to overcome those aspects
within you that puts you in conflict
with yourself and others to overcome
ignorance and prejudice and irrational
fear
to do this you must seek knowledge in
ways that you don't isolate yourself in
an ivory tower but immerse yourself
regularly in communities of knowledge
seeking far and wide connecting with
people everywhere
and bringing the book of their soul into
your own
after this i was recently in in
havana cuba
and i held a dialogue with people there
and they said you know
it's wonderful we've got a hundred
percent literacy there
all of us can reach they said you don't
even have that in the united states
but the problem is the woman said to me
is we're told what we can and cannot
read
and i think that in a free society even
the moment you let your guard down
watch it because suddenly you may not be
able to
read everything that you want to that
you want to get your hands on
and and i think it's telling that it's
not enough to have literacy it's not
enough to be able to read it's it's
important
to have that kind of choice that too
often we take for granted and i think
though that the first step begins quite
often with forms of foundational inquiry
that inspire people to become their own
best autonomous thinkers and expert
questioners because that in itself helps
them discover their own story first and
i think that impels them to read great
world literature and great world writing
and worldly writing about people from
across the world thank you very much
well we have plenty of opportunity for
questions and i'm sure that there will
be some so
if anyone would like to address a
question to one or the other or both of
our
panelists please do so
this is not so much a question it's just
an observation this young moment from
iran you can never go back can you once
you've tasted the ability to to converse
freely
and and that presents a danger for her
that's an
interesting point the students want to
go back and they admire for instance the
woman who won the nobel peace prize who
is sort of at the forefront of activism
there and would like to be able to do
what she's doing but since they're not
at her status
they can't they would be jailed but i
was thinking about reading lolita and
tehran and they remind me of those
characters there who came from a wide
range of ideologies and perspectives
from iran it's not like all muslims
think the same even those who consider
themselves progressive or fundamentalist
from a spectrum of colors wonderful
colors
um but they all kept their eyes on the
prize and read all these prohibited
books from the west together and became
these great inquirers and they never
lost sight of the fact that you can all
be from very different particular places
and yet share remarkably similar ideals
and one of the problems in the world is
that you just don't have a chance to do
that
the mind awfully hard i was thinking of
my own journey i was sort of in an
intellectual wasteland for a long time
and i
after about 10 years out of school i
realized i need to become
an autodidact again inspired one and
that led me down this wacky road that
eventually
germinated in the socrates cafe movement
so it's amazing once you start down that
journey of reading and thinking and
discovering where you might go
you know the financial advisor andrew
tobias once said a luxury once tasted
becomes a necessity and he was talking
about you know a plasma tv as opposed to
that rickety old thing he used to have
with the you know with the aluminum foil
on it uh but uh you know the same is
true for reading and thinking as well
there is there is you're right there is
no going back
yes yeah i uh i agree with professor
kirby's remark about
listening skills degrading and i wonder
if you might
either speaker might want to
say a little bit more about that um what
factors might have accounted for that
are there other cultures other times
when listening skills you could
say were were superior
and you mentioned um listening 101 i
mean it was meant to be an offhand
remark but if there were a course
listening 101 what would that uh
curriculum contain
it would probably be low tech i mean i
think part of the problem is that uh
is is that there's a there's a niche for
everything uh now there's there's a um
they're easy and cheap ways to identify
demographics and then and then have uh
you know a certain kind of uh
uh am talk show or certain kind of uh
show on on television that's that's uh
by and for
certain kind of people and that puts up
barriers and uh what you know what chris
is talking about is sitting around uh a
table what i'm talking about is you're
sitting around the the um the floor of a
not particularly clean uh rec room kind
of rolling around on on mats and saying
hey cut that out and then
uh let me you know let me tell you about
snow white so um
it where in a sense uh
i i guess i would be talking about so uh
going backward
um you know unplugging and sitting down
and and talking to people as we're
talking right now
i think that um
maybe there shouldn't necessarily be a
curriculum per se but some
forms of modeling
i've been in my travels particularly
in the dialogues i had with indigenous
groups in south africa and in chiapas
mexico
their indigenous tradition i would
characterize them as dialogue
communities
and they've never lost that sort of
tradition of
sitting
on dirt floors or wherever in
circles and and sharing
perspectives and the whole ideas to
uh just listen carefully
to what has been said before you there's
no paraphrasing afterwards or anything
you know by the way someone follows on
whether they've really understood where
you're coming from or not
and um and then maybe it also you can
have these great models of listening
from from very diverse cultural
communities and then
maybe on the other end of the spectrum
you might
show what you might not do and just show
a few examples from
the o'reilly factor and where the i
think the model is shut up or something
like that
or just a lot of
types of models where it seems like one
upsmanship and brow beating are the are
the rule and and the whole idea is to
get out your next zinger without really
listening carefully to what someone has
said before you rather than
having a reason argument even if it's
very well reasoned or debate just for
the sake of it the whole idea is to
use someone else's
carefully considered views as a
springboard for weighing and measuring
your own how can you do that if you
don't really
try to bring them into yourself to some
degree and that just takes a
lot of i mean i learned from my mom
my mom's always she was born and raised
in a mining camp in west virginia coal
mining camp but she was always just been
fascinated with listening to people's
stories that imprinted with me um
something rather in koat i think almost
magical about great listening and i i
like this idea don't don't you if
everyone is is right i mean if you've
you know if you've ever been married to
somebody or lived with somebody if
you're married to or living with
somebody you know you know that
everybody better be right most of the
time or you're gonna you know you're
gonna have trouble
um if you're gonna have a conversation
everybody has to be right which doesn't
mean everyone is always right if hitler
were here you know he would not be right
but but generally speaking uh you know
you you uh you grant the other person
his or her position and the the
conversation goes on otherwise no
conversation
it would seem as though fear is an
underlying cause for perhaps why this
doesn't happen if you look at the
conservative movement not just here but
worldwide
it's an adherence to our values
and feeling that they are under fire
whatever those values might be in
whatever culture and that seems to be
the antithesis of being open and
vulnerable
and questioning as though somehow
the others are going to come in and tell
you what to do so it's kind of like
digging your heels in and that seems to
be in my lifetime going on more now
than it has for decades so i'd like
either one of you to comment on that
yeah i think to uh
to put your hands in your pockets and
stretch your legs out and
sort of go ah it takes a tremendous act
of courage
you know it's uh it's easy to jump up
and get into someone's face but but i
think if you if you just relax and sit
back and and listen you're doing maybe
the bravest thing you can do
i think i've met many
progressives people who consider
themselves very liberal who are very
entrenched and fixed in their viewpoints
i've met many orthodox fundamentalists
conservative people who are extremely
open to where others are coming from
quite often the people that you see
on
half-hour news segments who
are people who are on the sensational
extreme of both ends who the media would
like you to think are the typical ones
who classify themselves as such but
quite often are not at all
again i think it's not a matter of
necessarily operating from the premise
that i
i'm right and that you're wrong
but that let's let's find out by
inquiring together where i might be
right
and where my views don't pass muster but
that does take a certain amount of
hutzpah
to just simply open yourself up for the
kind of scrutiny that you don't where
you don't necessarily feel threatened
but you actually feel may be forced and
inspired
to support your view in a way that you
wouldn't in a typical conflict the
problem too often these days and in too
many of our models is that
people
aren't listening to you they're
interrupting you and they're quickly
trying to put you down on purpose and
that isn't the tradition that we come
from i mean even our founding fathers
had these wonderful
wonderfully diverse passion views they
formed committees of correspondence and
inquiry circle groups really all all
around the various states
and they did have at it with one another
but they operated from a foundation
of abiding respect and integrity where
they really welcome the possibility of
having their views changed and i think
we need to resuscitate that tradition
again
yes
i was just thinking you were discussing
listening 101 but the opportunities for
children in elementary school middle
school and high school to even dialogue
is
over overshadowed by the fact that they
have to cover curriculum all the time so
they never get the opportunity not only
to speak
but to learn how to
listen and ask appropriate
questions so i wondered you know how can
we deal with those kinds of issues when
in elementary school middle school and
high school we're not given those
opportunities
did everyone hear the question excuse me
sure
now
the question was um well particularly
about elementary school where the
pressure by the standards of learning uh
requirements or seeming to diminish the
opportunities for
dialogue questioning the kind of thing
which our speakers are talking about the
virtues they're trying to inculcate
and so the problem is our education
system seems to be gravitating against
that
uh sort of openness and dialogue
yeah that that's a that's a tough one uh
because uh
uh i tell my college students uh it will
you know drink more coffee because they
always say how can i do all of this
stuff and i said well you know make
coffee stay up late
uh but you know you can't advise a
fourth grader to to go to starbucks uh
it would be nice if they could do those
standardized tests and and uh
and talk to each other at the same time
but
you're gonna have to solve this one
chris
you know one one thing that does gets uh
we don't stress enough is that our
non-profit society for philosophical
inquiry the major thrust of it is
outreach to children
we we have about 50 ongoing programs now
within schools for gifted children at
risk children regular children actually
i've never met a regular child so
but the ideas with teachers is that it
actually helps them fulfill their
mandates by
giving children a chance to inquire
together where they're just inquiring as
fellow human beings
even just for 20 or 30 blessed minutes a
week where the teacher takes off that
teacher's hat the kids take off that and
they're just inquiring as inquisitive
souls and it's astonishes teachers quite
often
they children that they had cubbyholed a
certain way
they realized that they had been
listening and they're actually able to
draw from many of the different
disciplines that they've been learning
from and revealing disparate likenesses
between them so it gives them a chance
to sort of mold and develop and
cultivate both their imaginative poetic
sensibilities in tandem with their
scientific and critical thinking skills
but that is that is actually one of the
biggest thrusts of what we try to do and
i'm
we're quite thrilled that it's it's been
touching accord with more and more
schools around the nation
this this christmas program is great in
that sense that it's sort of
um it systematizes uh
chaos i mean it packages it uh you know
you can't just say okay well let's we're
gonna work on the standardized test and
then you know go out and talk to each
other you know it's it's a it's a
program that brings into the school this
this possibility you know the uh the
choreographer george balanchine said the
reason why choreography exists is that
if it doesn't that the dance won't
happen or it won't happen at a good
level because when you're dancing you
get tired and so if you see a leap
coming up 17 steps down the stage and
and you feel tired and and uh you you uh
you don't have the option you won't do
it whereas if it's in the choreography
then then you're going to do it so you
know build build this kind of thing into
the system and it'll happen i think
that's really well put and it's sort of
a great dialogue at its finest
especially with kids as a kind of dance
and the ideas that they're
doing writing up and designing their own
choreography where they can sort of take
the lead on their own because ultimately
the idea is for you to become your own
best lifelong learner and somehow that
quite often gets lost in the hurley
burley of trying to meet mandates and
standardized test scores
when quite often it's qualitative and
anecdotal measurements which really are
the best gauges of determining a child's
development
yes
the lady
yes well i have a question for egypt
speakers first for you you made a
passing reference to
a conversation that's been going on for
what centuries i think he said
i was curious as to what you meant i
wish you could elaborate on that and i
wanted to ask you for someone who's
never heard of
the socrates
cafes
um you know what they're all about i
think i might want to join one
could i repeat the question just in case
people in the back didn't hear the first
was addressed to uh professor kirby
about the conversation that's been going
on for centuries just what is he talking
about precisely and for um
chris collins um
tell us phillips i'm sorry where did
that come from um
i'll have a chris collins please to go
oh okay thank you
chris collins is a champion the
basketball player chris phillips is an
athlete of another kind right exactly
um uh questions what what are the
socrates cafes and how do they work and
uh more information a little more
information about them so the the uh
if you put the words great conversation
into your favorite search engine you'll
you'll come across the names mortimer
adler and robert hutchins who founded
the the great books series and their
idea was that
was that the books talk to each other uh
and that if you pick up a copy of a
thomas hardy novel and just read it cold
you know you it'll kind of it'll make a
certain kind of sense but when you read
thomas hardy then you go back and you
read a socratic
dialogue you can say well i see that
what's going on in socrates shows up
later in this slightly different form in
in thomas hardy then you move up into
the 20th century you're reading virginia
woolf and that kind of connects so you
see wolf and hardy and and socrates all
kind of jabbering to each other
tomorrow there's some events that are
going on with uh regard to the 150th
anniversary of
walt whitman's leaves of grass and
whitman is is
one of my students uh would as one of my
students but he's one of my elvi he's
one of the elvises that i that i worship
because you know whitman believed in
walking around and talking to professors
but talking to blacksmiths
to and and freed slaves and prostitutes
you know every come one come on give me
your poor you're tired you're huddled
masses whitman liked
listened to
talk to
everybody so i think the great
conversation is not just socrates and
thomas hardy and virginia woolf and all
those books on the shelf but it's it's
it's everybody has something to say
so what is a socrates cafe well talk to
that wonderful man right in front of you
ken he's got an ongoing group here
that's been meeting for many years now
he's got some membership cards in his
pocket never no never have to join any
take care no strings attached check
books
um gold rings we have about um
we do have about 300 groups now the
socrates cafe is more of a concept in a
particular place it's something that can
take place on a mountaintop in a maximum
security prison homeless shelter cafe
bookstore and the whole idea
is to gather with people
where
you
not only have the courage of your
convictions but you have the courage to
have your convictions challenged in ways
that hopefully
inspire you to develop and articulate
and in fact discover further your
viewpoints than you would if you were
just left to your own devices
um our non-profit group website at
philosopher.org
has a very thorough guide on on what
it's about and and how what the ethos is
because i think that inquiry
methodical inquiry
divorced from an ethos of respectful and
empathetic listening doesn't leave you
with much so again the idea is to gather
with people on a regular basis friends
and strangers alike
in ways that you can in a group setting
can further discover your own unique
way of world viewing and world making so
it is that you can
a group setting doesn't have to lead to
group think or consensus or even closure
but it can lead to greater autonomy
and sense of social conscience at the
same time i would think
um
and i think that quite i
done thousands of these myself not i
never fail to learn something new about
myself but it also makes me feel more
connected with the world
yes
well that's a perfect segue
both of you gentlemen have a question
you've got
a question
as your book title and you've got
question in your book title
um and i know from doing the socrates
cafe uh process
that
it's entirely built on questions and i
think that might be a partial answer to
how we get a listening 101 curriculum
because by asking a question
we create the opportunity to listen
which otherwise would not be present so
with that in mind i would like to ask
each of you
what do you think is the
question that generates the greatest
amount of interest
when you speak to people
did everyone hear that the question is
the final question was what is the
question that generates the greatest
amount of interest
that's the question right there there
next question please no i i think that
what i'm getting asked more and more
often now that i
have been privileged to travel a great
deal is are people asking
the same sorts of questions everywhere
are there are they asking very different
types of questions depending on where i
go
and what has astonished me is how
similar
the questions are in a sense they're
always a little bit different i've never
been asked the same question twice
frankly never facilitated socrates cafe
the same question twice in an ongoing
group but um just sort of where are we
going
where are we going from here people are
sort of concerned that
both local and global society is on both
a crossroads and a precipice at the same
time and the questions seem to be
springing out of that
general concern
i'm a regular
egghead
academic which means that i i avoid
giving answers and sidestep them as much
as possible and try to raise questions
and then sneak away quietly before
people find out that i don't know what
i'm talking about
so so one of the things i do when i talk
to um different groups and they can be
little kids or or
middle schoolers or college students or
grad students or or groups like you is
is you know is is a sort of a you know
a version of what is it that you you um
you wonder about and the thing that
keeps coming up again and again
uh you can phrase it in different ways
uh i guess it would be uh what happens
after we die or is there an afterlife or
some version of that which isn't really
a question it's partly a question it's
partly wishful thinking isn't it
you hope something good but uh
except for shirley maclaine no one's
come back and reported yet
yes you mentioned uh censorship in a
highly literate population such as cuba
and i wondered if uh
either of you or both of you could
comment on a literacy in the united
states
question was comment on a literacy in
the united states
it's a growth industry
it's
i really have to take my blood pressure
pill when i
talk to an english major who says i
don't like to read
you know
yours just went up too ma'am right yeah
i heard it uh
i opened a copy of newsweek it was a
complimentary copy of
newsweek in my hotel room today it said
68 percent of
people between 8 and 18 have a tv in
their bedroom
if you have access
to the plug on one of those tvs i would
recommend that you pull it i can't
imagine what sort of domestic chaos it
would it would uh it would wreak but
still um
you know we we uh
we watch a lot of television we don't we
don't read the way we used to and you
know i watch i watch
television as well
and uh
and and love it some of it's some of
it's fabulous and uh
i hate to sound like a broken record
personally i have to keep going back to
my more coffee solution you know if i
watch too much tv i brew up a pot and
stay up and
and read a couple of good books until i
hear the birds but uh i again you can't
tell that to an eight or an 18 year old
so
uh you know there must be a better way
to
to
get young people to
to unplug and to talk to be low tech as
i said earlier and i think you know
chris has got the idea
you know
the places there used to be great
escapes for reading
airport terminals
motel lobbies where you go down and have
your breakfast
now there's like an altar an enormous tv
everywhere and people just
go down and are glued to it cecilia and
i don't have a tv we don't have a plug
to pull
though when of course when i'm traveling
i do watch it from time to time but i
think that
it's it's a it is sort of a big
contributing factor it's it
just this real apathy towards reading i
can't i get emails all the time from
people who want to write books but like
you said they don't well i don't want to
read anything i want i want to write
something on my own instead of realizing
and and being part of and wanting to be
part of this incredible tradition
and knowing
knowing the tradition among among the
ages and across cultures and disciplines
and
best you can do is just try to be an i
think an example of that in a time when
it's becoming sort of an endangered
species
yes way in the back um
this kind of relates a little bit to
television but
when one of the questions down here was
how can we incorporate listening into a
school's elementary junior high my
question is of all of the
verbiage about how to raise your
children and where to take them and what
skills to learn i've really never heard
of anyone and i've often wondered about
this saying sit down and listen to your
who your child really is what they like
to talk about what they like to do
and most of my friends when i had small
children were directing their kids
rather than
sitting down and listening to who they
were so why isn't that a part of modern
american how to treat your kids
culture and it doesn't seem to be
on the family level
um
you know my my favorite book that i've
written is philosophers club my
children's book and it's based on
verbatim dialogues
that i've held with children i mean why
aren't things this way
or why do they have to be this way i
think we have to create new traditions
where
we
open up pathways of communication with
children so that we see them as equal
human beings so we really want to hear
their stories one of them
but again this can be a self-fulfilling
prophecy if we if just because that's
what we don't see right now it's all the
more reason is as individuals to try to
model it and then maybe eventually we
will see it in a good housekeeping all
these things start with a parent here an
adult there a teacher there deciding
this isn't the right traditions we
should be establishing and maybe we can
develop other other pathways of engaging
children so
i mean
quite often the assumption is well what
do i have to learn from a kid
but you know i've never been i may have
been four or five or six years old or 10
years old but i've never been one in
year 2005 with what's going on in the
world right now i think it almost
behooves us
to engage with them in ways that
we want to convey to them that we really
want to know what's going on with them
and
why do i only hear this in erudite
society talks why don't i hear it
anyplace else well because slowly but
surely
a parent here there needs to
take the initiative to try to create an
alternative that to that and maybe then
you will hear it more it's a it's a
great shame that you're not
yes uh yes
very quick question
do you train does your organization
train teachers in socratic method with
with with children yes we travel to
schools regularly to hold dialogues and
give workshops to educators
there's an enormous amount in our
schools right now of kids sitting down
in circles and just
talking right but but there isn't very
much
kind of directed and
facilitated talking that facilitated you
know in in a way that's
really going to lead somewhere not
somewhere that people have thought of
first robert frost said it's a fake poem
and no poem at all if you've the best is
thought up first and save for last but
but but but anyway to have some
some some real guide guidance and some
some some training of teachers in how to
challenge the the the kids and push them
forward absolutely i mean it's a learned
skill and it's some cecilia and i are
both certified teachers and we travel
regularly it's
it's a it's a method that we impart to
educators in how to engage kids in ways
that lends itself to the surprise of the
novel and the unfamiliar but there is an
undergirding method to that and that is
what we
teach it's a rigorous method but it is
accessible and it takes a great deal of
practice many times we visit a school
more than once
we go to the new mexico school for the
deaf in santa fe one week every semester
we're philosophers and residents there
to sort of
go and help troubleshoot and help them
see where there might
still need some areas of learning how to
do this this is a learning skill and it
takes i'm still learning how to do it
it's it's one of those things that lends
itself always to greater evolution
adaptation
it was yes
in
opening
an opportunity for children in school to
to talk to one another uh what do you
what happens with the conflict
where a child
believes in his or her parents and what
they believe in
and
opening himself up to what other kids
and that and their parents believe most
kids are that way any anyway uh
you know they they uh they're they're
wise and nimble like thumbling
and uh
and and know that uh
you know you talk to your per you you
talk to your parents one way
and uh you know you talk to your friends
another not not in a way that's
seditious or treacherous it's just that
uh it's a it's a kind of multilingual
approach isn't it
about behavior or personality i'm
talking about just core values i still i
am too yeah i i still believe what most
of what
my parents believe that
now some things i i don't but
most things i still feel are
that they felt are true are true in my
life well you have those ideas because
those values came in in conflict with
others at at some point and and the the
point i would think would be to make a
context in which in which there can be
that sort of
sort of fruitful uh cross-pollination
and growth
uh which which takes some pretty
skillful teaching
uh
you know good good good teachers are um
are hard to train uh hard hard to come
by and and uh
you know
you know what teachers make in this
country
uh and uh and you know the effect that's
uh
that's having so so let's uh let's stick
up for higher teachers salaries and and
make it possible for people to to you
know to create a context in which a kid
who is who hears one thing or believes
one thing at home can come into a school
and talk to people who believe uh
something
differently and don't think that that
the person they're talking to is the
spawn of satan
but somebody just with a
with a different idea that is that is
right in another way i have to tell you
my experience is that
kids when they're away from their
parents
they are very quick to
develop
and sculpt their own views i have much
more problem with adults
getting them to think outside the box a
little bit than i do with
kids um
i find the only difference i find is the
kids quite often are different when
they're
uh
parent or caregivers with them they'll
sort of look at them to make sure that
what they're saying is okay but as soon
as they're left to their
own devices
they flourish pretty quickly
if given the license to
and quite often that
is determined by the teacher
if the answer quite often a teacher will
say well i don't see what that has to do
with what we're talking about or already
has a preset list of what an acceptable
response is
so quite often children speak a
different language that we adults don't
readily understand and that's one of the
big impediments is to give a child
enough time to explain his or her story
so we can find out for sure whether it
does or doesn't because quite often we
make very preemptive judgments about
that and that's where very careful
training and listening comes in to to
make sure that we're
taking the time to let a child develop
and elaborate her point of view
your account of how the japanese
children in that school room changed
after the teacher left the room
and suddenly they opened up and started
speaking and they were just worried
about what the teacher would think about
whether they were saying the correct as
soon as the teacher left i mean because
it's all about getting the good grade
there and passing the standardized tests
or otherwise you don't go to the school
of your choice but as soon as the
teacher left those kids sudden we talked
about the question what is courage and
they started talking about the yakuza
the japanese mafia and the ninja at
first had been well courage is doing all
your homework when your friends want to
play
[Laughter]
i mean give me a break
but oh they soared as soon as that
person that was in there who they felt
was grading them and judging them
yes this is going to sound like a very
strange question but i was a freshman in
college fresh from the hills of vermont
taking a sociology course and the
professor said our values absolute or
relative and i decided to chair the one
that said they're absolute
um
and it was so disconcerting to me not to
lose in the sense of of competition but
i'd never believed that my methodist
values from rutland vermont
were anything but the absolute values of
the world so i think there's an
emotional component sometimes when you
go away from something and say well gee
maybe what i've been taught
isn't
the only truth um and that was something
that wasn't pressured by teachers or
parents it was an internal kind of thing
and i think it can be unsettling i'm not
saying i'm not saying it shouldn't
happen but it can be unsettling and
maybe that's the whole purpose of it
anyway
i think that's the whole purpose of
dorm room bs sessions i mean uh you know
i hope my students take something away
from
what i talk about with them in the
classroom but you know i think it's
those late late night um
uh
you know
challenging uh sessions that go on and
on until the sun comes up
that are as
important as anything else that happens
in the lab or the or the classroom
i mean unsettling can be good it can be
wonderful so many people like sartre
would describe as stone
there even seems to be something about
if you actually change your mind after
carefully considering other perspectives
that you're somehow a flip-flopper
stereotyped
instead of somebody who's actually
thought carefully and has the courage to
change her mind over time as she opens
herself up to other perspectives
uh yes
i'm still stuck on the english major who
doesn't like to read
can you just ruin your evening well i
just can't get a handle around that can
can you just talk a little how would
that come about
why would somebody choose
i can you just talk a little more about
that
i think chris talked about it a minute
ago he said they probably want to be
writers but they don't want to they
don't want to read to learn how to how
to write uh
you know it's uh it's uh i i it's my
fault probably and they look at me i'm a
pretty pretty happy guy and get to talk
to to people like you
and uh so it's they say i wanna i to be
like you uh but i don't want to read
i say well i've got a plan for you you
know which is
actually it's a map it's
leads to the library you know get busy
two quick observations my daughter's a
freshman in college she had taken
courses in texas and she's taking
courses in massachusetts and there is an
inherent bias
and you can tell between the two places
one is very liberal and it's very hard
to express his conservative opinion
there
and one is more conservative and it's
harder you know and i don't even think
the professors are aware of themselves
and how they put that out
and
so you know that's something about
teaching teachers but in some sense it's
teaching people about themselves and how
they're viewed by their college students
high school students whatever you know
you can sort of watch a student's
politics change color as as that student
leaves uh
you know the the sociology uh bill
building where he's
had a social work class and he's going
in and to to his economics class and you
know as he goes there he sort of becomes
a keynesian uh
economist and then when that's over he
walks over and he and he talks to his uh
um
you know english english professor and
suddenly he's a lot pinker than than he
used to be an hour ago
and then he goes to his class of marxism
and you know
goodness gracious he's totally red and
then uh you know these these students
i'm not saying they're hypocritical but
you know they're pretty savvy
social creatures and i love my students
because they're they are they are
flexible still they haven't grown up
into this adult rigidity and you know
that what they're doing is they're
trying on different colors they're
trying on different uh you know uh
political intellectual cultural
philosophical orientations and what
they're gonna do is what all of us did
they're gonna put together their own
gumbo they're gonna put together their
own mix of these things and be
themselves someday
it's hard for her to have a discussion
with her professor
when he basically says
well that's a stupid idea that people
held 50 years ago or
that's only the idea held by the pc
people at yale and we don't talk about
that here or you know not not that
blatant but the undertone is there
she's i i'm gathering that
as she is
your daughter that she probably is able
to
to um
stand up to the to these uh
dinosaurs
uh
and and that she'll do okay
but as a former as a former professor no
one ever talked to me about that and you
know and as as he was talking about
teaching teachers
you know i don't think there's anything
that even even my colleagues that i
don't that i don't agree with and
they're probably more of those than than
the ones that i do
uh i think they're doing the right thing
and that you can't really you can't
really teach without a little bit of
prejudice or a lot of prejudice you
can't teach without a little a little
bit of tabasco uh in your uh
remarks i mean if you go around saying
um
well you know all of this stuff is
pretty pleasant i hope you enjoy
my class that's one thing but but if you
know if you if you say dante is uh great
or dante's
uh politics are terrific but he was an
idiot as far as religion goes uh then
you know you know
you wake them up
you know you're throwing some water in
in their their face so um even even
somebody who says uh you know you're
you're uh even somebody who makes this
kind of statement kind of provocative
statement that uh
that uh you're talking about here is is
right in a sense you're presuming as a
certain modicum of good manners and
respect for for the students uh opinion
but uh but most of these students are
pretty tough and can and can stand and
even welcome it when their buttons are
pushed you know the best teachers i ever
had whether it was in elementary school
or at uh
college or graduate school were ones who
they they did have their very
firm positions quite often but at the
same time they never expected me to
share their positions and they in fact
encouraged me to come up with my own
everything that i've done since then has
been
decidedly influenced by scholars mostly
my professors from college encouraged me
but they
they're not all like that but even if
you can come across a few who really do
not try to validate any and every
opinion but really try to inspire you to
develop
and cultivate carefully your own unique
perspective on whatever the subject is
i think we have time for one more
question yes
i wonder how important peer pressure
might be in this too kids who
are afraid to
appear too bookish or too uh
uncool in their views or something like
that so they just don't speak up
the great the great thing about about
you know these public universities like
this one right here is that it really
isn't one place it's a lot of little
villages then go from one village
to to another and uh right now i'm
teaching an honors
class and i run to that class every time
because uh these kids are so i mean
they're like a bunch of i mean you know
they're 20 years old and you think if i
said look there's a 20 year old in the
other room you'd think he was a kind of
a slack you know goth
kid you know smoking a clove cigarette
and uh
and being irreverent and
you know uncaring but but but these kids
are like they're like third graders i
mean they hold their hands up and they
you know they want to talk and to them
it's it is cool to be bookish it is it
is cool to to talk about
uh
poetry and language study and uh
electrical engineering well not
electrical engineering but um
but uh you know the kinds of things that
they major in and and and uh and and
love and uh you know they've they have
formed their own little village of this
kind of person their own tribe
uh as it were does that make sense in
terms of you what you're yeah you have
tribes
yeah in fact women mary my colleagues
it's our
the women mary tribe
yeah
the um
there's only some communities in the
united states is it ever a stigma
to
be bookish
anywhere else i've gone whether it's in
in in mexico or career japan you're held
in great honor
if you're well read
when we go to chiapas and have something
to do with the kids they always sort of
defer to the one or two of them who've
actually had the luxury of learning how
to read
and they're they're held in very much
high esteem and i think what a
what does it say about a societal
community that somehow there's that
mindset that he who has read the most
should in any way be apologetic or even
embarrassed by it or stigmatized heaven
forbid it should be just the opposite
well um we want to thank you i remind
you again please to fill out the survey
forms and leave them with the volunteers
on the way i want to thank our two
speakers
this panel was part of the 11th annual
virginia festival of the book in
charlottesville virginia
visit vabook.org
for more information
coming up at 8 a.m eastern a children's
book on the life and philosophy of
socrates
then reporter jackie spinner uncovering
the iraq war and her twin sister jenny
describes the impact on their family
tonight on book tv
menace and europe
claire berlinsky on continental politics
culture and social conditions
after that the global class war
jeff faux on free trade and economic
imperialism
and at 10 pm eastern the walmart effect
charles fishman on the economic impact
of the retail giant
[Music]
university of vermont classics professor
m.d usher writes about greek philosopher
socrates in his book for young readers
wise wiseguy he spoke about it with a
group of children at barnes and noble
booksellers in south burlington vermont
for 35 minutes
m.d usher is a classics professor at the
university of vermont and in addition to
publishing academic articles he has now
made the foray into children's
literature and wise guy is his first
book for children so please help us
welcome mr mark usher
[Applause]
thank you nance it's a pleasure to be
here
and a pleasure to uh be able to read
this book with you um i think it's
interesting that um socrates himself
never wrote a word
though he was such an influential
guy
that he gave other people a lot of ideas
and many other people wrote about
socrates i'm the last in the line of
many more important people than myself
who have written about socrates so it's
very interesting that he uh he did
inspire uh many many other people though
he never wrote a word himself
um he could write but he just chose not
to he liked to talk and he liked to ask
questions
so this is uh the book that i wrote
wiseguy the life and philosophy of
socrates um the illustrations were done
by
a man named william bramhall
um
and i think i think you like the story
and i know you'll like the pictures the
pictures are really good
um what i'm going to do is i'm going to
read the text
and and then maybe ask you questions
about it you can tell me what you see in
these pictures and um see what kind of
ideas percolate for you as we uh as we
read it
um
you're not too old for this book so i
don't know what ages you are here but no
one's too old for socrates and no one's
too old for philosophy and no one's too
young for philosophy or socrates
long ago
in ancient greece
a boy named socrates declared that all
he knew was nothing
so he spent his whole life asking
questions
he was a curious boy
and cheeky too
but more than anything in all the world
he wanted to be happy
he wanted to be good
and he wanted to be wise
now
we're socrates in this picture do you
think
jd yeah right there what kind of guy
does he look like to you
about how old do you think there
how old um
seven yeah good seven or eight and uh
the funny thing is it was hard for me to
know what socrates was like as a child
because we don't know anything about
what he was like as a child we know what
he was like when he grew up and when he
grew up we know that he was a cheeky
little monkey he asked all sorts of
tough questions of people um and he was
very childlike when he grew up so i had
to imagine him as a child and and there
he is and that's how the artist
portrayed him with that rakish
hair part and leaning up against the uh
the the column in athens um anybody know
what this building might be this is in
athens ancient greece athens was
socrates uh hometown
anybody know what that building is
yeah it's called the parthenon
and it's a big temple
that was built for athena and socrates
would spend a lot of his time
down in this area here in the shadow of
the acropolis um which is called the
agora and that's where he would ask his
questions and and soak up the sun and
talk to people yes noah i have a magnet
that is a three-dimensional
parthenon that goes on the fridge
oh that's great oh that's wonderful
that's good
thank you
all right
do you think everybody wants to be happy
in life i think everybody wants to be
good
you might be right not everybody might
be right not everybody does not
necessarily want to be good i imagine
you all do how about wise
yeah good
every day he went to see his friend
a cobbler named simon
he sat and studied simon while he worked
simon cut leather into strips and
stitched the pieces carefully together
into shoes
he was an excellent cobbler
hmm
socrates wondered
is cobbling a kind of wisdom
what do you think you think cobbling
might be a kind of wisdom
[Music]
absolutely and what kind of skills do
you need
to make make shoes
you have to know
how to choose leather right and then you
have to know how to cut it into the
right shape and you have to know how to
stitch it together it takes knowledge to
be to be a cobbler and what socrates
thought when he saw the cobbler he said
hmm i wonder if you know
wisdom is that sort of same sort of
thing that you have to be an expert
you have to train you have to become
good at thinking
to have wisdom and he thought that yes
you did you had to have a skill at
thinking and it just doesn't come
naturally you have to practice it to get
good at it
and so that was part of what his
questions were all about
this guy actually
though we don't know what socrates was
when he what he was like when he was a
child this guy we know was the first guy
to write socratic dialogues he basically
recorded his conversations with socrates
probably held when socrates visited his
cobbling shop so
while simon worked socrates would ask
him questions and they would have
conversations
he's a real guy
don't you like that
line that the artist did there the eyes
meeting the
the shoe
he also watched a carpenter in town
built furniture from wood
first the carpenter built a bed then he
built a table
each is finely crafted as the other
hmm
socrates pondered
if both are made of wood and have four
legs what makes one a table and one a
bed
and what makes a carpenter a carpenter
socrates scratched his head
it must have something to do with ideas
he decided
so here's the question of the day i give
an a to the a for the day anyone who can
answer this what makes what's the
difference between a table and a chair
if they both have four legs
and they're made out of wood
yep jd yes
[Music]
okay good the chair has a back where the
table doesn't have a bag good
that's that's true that's very good noah
um maybe that you can put food on a
table yeah and put chairs around it sure
what do you do with a chair you don't
put food on a chair right
you sit on it you sit on a chair right
you don't usually sit on the table
that's well yeah you can sit on a table
i suppose but teachers always try to get
off the table if you're sitting on the
table
very good so it has to do with the
function of the object and um so things
are defined by what they do or what
they're used for as opposed to just what
they look like
now
i want to see how clever you guys are
what do you think about this picture
what's the relationship of
that chair
to the picture that socrates is looking
at
yeah julia yes
brilliant very good yes this is actually
a diagram of the actual chair that
socrates is sitting in it's a blueprint
and socrates looked at that looked at
the carpenter and he looked at his
carpenter's blueprint and looked at the
chair that the carpenter made and he
said hmm the carpenter has to have an
idea of the chair before he can even
start building one
and that idea he gets the idea from the
blueprint or he draws the blueprint from
his idea and then he builds the chair
socrates probably thought i know that
plato that was um socrates's great
student who wrote a lot about socrates
later a great philosopher
he thought that all things have a
blueprint to which they correspond
including things like right and wrong
good and bad
happy and sad
there was like a blueprint that you had
to follow to or understand to understand
what these things were
and that's what socrates discovered in
in the carpenter shop
he thought a lot about ideas and
questioned everyone to find out more
what about ideas you cannot see as you
would a table or a bed
what is goodness
what is courage
what is justice
what is love
though important people huffed and
puffed claiming to know the answers and
pretending to be wise
he found that no one understood ideas as
simon understood his leather or the
carpenter his wood
how can you be truly wise if you don't
know what these things are socrates
asked
all right so here's some big questions
what do you think something what do you
think courage is
what is courage as we commonly use it
what does it mean to be courageous
any ideas
doing something that is dangerous or
something that no one has done before
so the ability to face something that is
dangerous without flinching or without
running away from it
that's that's a good that's a good
definition and then what socrates would
do is he would ask you hmm what do you
mean by good what do you mean by
all around and find their weak points
that's very good
so what do you think what do you think
socrates is thinking
about these guys over here they are very
moderate what is it they aren't very
wise yeah they aren't very wise do they
do they look to you that they think
they're very wise
they think they're wise but they find
out they are but they're not and they
pretend they are and everyone doesn't
want to offend them
so they don't figure out that they are
wise
that's great um socrates really
he looked around him and he thought that
people thought they knew a lot more than
they actually did
and that's the another reason why he was
determined to ask questions not just of
other people but of himself
and not settle for easy answers he
always asks questions so you can see in
his eyes there he says you really don't
quite know what you're talking about do
you
um of course they're very proud and they
think that they do
that's what cheekiness is and they're
saying oh he's just a little boy
that's right and they probably dismissed
him as just a little boy though he was
asking the big questions and the
important ones you're absolutely right
yeah
well people did listen closely to his
questions
they'd sit outside for hours in the warm
inviting sun
hmm socrates said looking up into the
sky
do you think goodness might be like the
sun
the source of vision light and life
now what's happened to socrates between
that page previous and this page here
he's he's grown up some huh yes
and now socrates is is grown up but he's
still asking questions he didn't outgrow
all those questions that he was asking
as a child he continued to ask him and
people were very interested in the kind
of questions he asked
and boy that's where i'd rather be right
now i tell you instead of cold vermont
in that field with that sun shining
overhead
but socrates uh saw in the sun uh an
image of something even bigger than
itself uh the source of light and life
um and he thought that the sun was a lot
like goodness
it causes things to grow
um and uh and causes the earth and the
world to flourish
and he thought that there was some sort
of
moral quality in the world some sort of
other quality not a physical entity like
the sun but something
non-physical
that um that
caused goodness to exist in the world
and that people could understand it
if we asked the right questions and if
we were determined to
uh follow through on the answers that we
came up with
and when the sun went down as it always
does
socrates would spend the night with
friends they'd eat drink and talk
and dance
socrates love to dance and wave his arms
and twist his hips
the body like the mind he said must be
nimble fit
and strong
so let's go back to this page here
and
what are they doing they're sitting down
they're drinking eating olives and bread
and drinking wine this is what the
greeks love to do more than anything
else was sit down and talk and so
socrates fit right in
and so you love to ask questions
and um
well what else do you see in this
picture another what is she doing
playing pipes yeah she has a kind of
like a bagpipe
instrument there this is called an alas
and what would happen at a gathering
like this and the greeks were very fond
of such gatherings called the symposium
actually we still use that word for
modern lectures and and
places where people give have
conversations and give lectures um the
symposium they would lie down together
recline on couches drink wine and listen
to music and do things like recite
poetry and talk philosophy and this is
this was socrates's favorite hangout
this is what he would do after hours
spend all day in the marketplace or
outside talking to friends and then even
at night he'd sit down and talk with
friends he was so determined to ask
questions
yes and he wasn't afraid to have fun
either
being a philosopher isn't just about
being all serious and being good isn't
all just about being all serious and and
you can have fun as a as a philosopher
as well
and that's actually true socrates did
love to dance
i don't know how he could snap his
fingers and move his feet at the same
time that's like patting your head and
rubbing your tummy standing on one foot
you can do it well i'm
glad i couldn't do it
anybody been to greece or
know anything the greeks still love to
dance you can't you can't even you can't
go anywhere without the greeks trying to
get you to dance with them
but he was not a very handsome man
some people ridiculed the way he looked
part crab part pig part donkey
he didn't mind their jokes
he just smiled and said
i see better with these bulging eyes
smell better with my turned up nose
kiss better with these donkey lips
now this is also true socrates was a
rather funny looking character
and uh and people couldn't help but
notice that he was funny looking and
some people
made fun of him now i'm sure that i
don't know have you been made fun of
before
i hope not but it's usually a fact of
life no you're lucky jd
i've been i've been made fun of before
and it's it's sometimes hurtful it's
hard to take but but socrates was wise
he knew the thing to do when somebody
made fun of you is to
absorb it not to retaliate and fight
back not to be hurt but make a make
light of it make a joke of it and so
yeah he said yeah my eyes are bulging
but i can see a lot better
my nose is turned up kind of like a
pig's nose but makes me smell a lot
better
and he said uh my lips okay they're a
little bit floppy and flappy but i'm a
much better kisser because of them
now this character here i don't know he
almost looks alive doesn't he i think
it's a statue
and the greeks were very famous for
their love of beauty i don't know if
you've ever seen a greek statue
before some statue from ancient greece
they're always perfectly proportioned
the socrates didn't fit in with those
classical ideals and so they're having
sort of a beauty contest here
i don't know i think i like socrates
better
socrates was also poor
but happy with the things he had
look at all the things i do not need
he'd say with a laugh whenever he went
shopping
look at that he's self-sufficient
what kind of things do you see in that
picture
yes
drugs i've seen him in a picture before
actually this guy is probably full of
oil or wine and
and
all this food over here and this woman's
buying jewelry
socrates thought that less was more he
also thought
that the best things in life aren't
things he didn't quite say it that way
that is what he thought
oh you need food you need food you're
exactly right you do need food and you
know from those previous pages that
socrates
like to eat and drink and enjoy himself
you do need food you're right about that
jd
but he thought that you you shouldn't
want more than you actually need
and you have to make up your mind about
what you actually need
and not so much listen to others and
follow what people say that you need
what do you think what do you think he
would have thought about modern
advertising all those years you guys
ever watch television
commercials yeah
yeah that makes they make ice cream like
out of plaster or something
they make fake food on television to
make you want to get food that doesn't
melt or doesn't get stuck oh they do
yeah i didn't know that gosh i'm glad i
don't have a television
but you yeah i don't have a television
i'm glad that you know that no one
that's that's good most a lot of people
don't know that yeah and i think it's
real when they want to buy it because
it's cool right
all right
and when he prayed which he sometimes
did
his prayer went like this
dear pan
and all you gods here
graciously grant that i be beautiful
within
and may my behavior in this world agree
with what with what is hidden underneath
this skin
and may i count the wise man rich
and desire only so much gold
as the modest purse of a prudent man
would want to have or hold
now there's socrates in his at a classic
pose this this prayer here actually
comes right from
a dialogue by a guy named plato the
famous philosopher plato it's translated
i translated it exactly from the
original greek it doesn't rhyme in the
greek but i wanted to make it rhyme to
sound more like a poem and maybe like a
prayer there
and now do you know who pan is he's
praying to the god pan do you know who
julia jopan is
um
not quite dude what kind of character is
this
you guys have maybe seen i don't know
like chronicles of narnia maybe or read
the books
what does he look like
a fawn yes and in fact fawns are you
know descendants of the ancient god pan
who was part uh goat-like and part-human
and he had horns on his head like that
um
and
he wasn't i mean the horns may be kind
of scary it doesn't look so scary in
that picture that kind of looks like bob
dylan to me very friendly looking uh a
friendly looking pan but um
but the uh
the greeks saw pan as a god of of
woodlands and pastors who lived out in
the wild who was self-sufficient kind of
the way socrates wanted to be
self-sufficient
close to nature
and and so socrates he rarely went out
of town he really went outside the city
walls but when he did he'd like to go
and sit underneath a plane tree and it's
quite appropriate that he would pray to
the pan the god of the the woods and the
pastures while he was out there
and so there he is praying to pan and
pan is kind of like his
alter ego he's kind of like socrates
in the way he looked
and his unattached uh the fact that he
was unattached to uh to to culture human
human civilization
um
anyway those mushrooms
i'm not sure they those existed in
greece or not
they look magical
don't eat them
poisonous mushrooms to make them they
were i think they were that kind of red
mushroom to make them go crazy in battle
oh wow yes yes
oh i love this picture apollo god of
wisdom love socrates dearly
no one is as good
or wise or as brave as he apollo said
the other gods agreed
now this is something we actually know
did happen and this is what this is what
happened apollo was the god of wisdom
the god of music and the god of medicine
and he had a sanctuary or a shrine or a
temple all of that actually at a place
called delphi
that's a place in greece very high up in
the mountains it's a beautiful place you
should go there take have your parents
take you there sometime
and socrates had a very close friend
named kairophon and kyrophon
wanted to find out just how wise
socrates really was because people were
saying that he's pretty smart he's
pretty wise people had a lot of
admiration for socrates so chirophon
went to the oracle at delphi and an
oracle is a place where you would go and
you get you'd ask the god a question and
god would give you an answer back and
kyrophon asked kind of like snow white
mirror mirror on the wall who's the
wisest of them all
who's the wisest person in athens and
the answer kai refund got back was
socrates
now remember the first page of this book
socrates said that he didn't know
anything the only thing that he knew was
that he knew nothing
so socrates when cairofon told them the
god's answer to his or to his question
he says how could i be the wisest person
of all i don't know a thing
and i know i don't know a thing
so he thought about it he thought about
he thought about he said it must be that
because i don't claim to know what i
don't know
that i must be the wisest person in the
world
so that he knew he was aware of his own
ignorance
um and so he spent the rest of his life
sort of on a divine mission from apollo
to ask people questions and show them
how little that they knew as well
anyway let's see god's here all right
here's here's a little quiz for you
that's apollo i'll tell you that okay
he's also the sun god and here's his
chariot that he did it
what's that
across the sky or something like that i
miss that
yes yes exactly yes good good good um
and how about this little god right
there in the middle with the wings and
the bow you know who he is you know who
he is
cupid yes exactly right and in greek
it's called eros but that's definitely
cupid um
now how about this goddess she's a
goddess and she carries a shield and she
what is it
athena very good very good sorry i
didn't hear that it is indeed athena
right look at her she duh
that's probably zeus and hera i'd have
to ask the illustrator who who's who
this is definitely modeled on many
paintings of this sort you see in
museums how about this guy here
you know who that guy is either his
greek or his roman name
that's a good yeah a good guess
not hercules god of war
you know what that would be
mars
mars or aries is called aries in in
greek i think that's who that is now how
about this guy okay i bet you would know
this he's got i'm sorry i got to move my
finger here
very good yes
you can't see his feet yes you can you
can see his feet right there and he's
got wings on it that's hermes or mercury
very good
um yeah and i'm not quite sure who this
is that might be dionysus believe it or
not that would be a guy that's got a
wine that might be beside i'm not sure
assigned god obscenes
but anyway i love that picture and look
at
this
scratching his head
but certain men were not so pleased
how can a man who says that he knows
nothing be the wisest man of all
they grumbled
they felt threatened
they were jealous and embarrassed
so they accused the thinker socrates of
things he never did or said then they
sent him off
to jail
just really happened
socrates was sad
nevertheless he said
it is still better to suffer or wrong
than to commit one
so socrates was accused of well three
things really
one thing was he was accused of
corrupting the youth
people like
you people thought that he got people
asking he got other people asking too
many questions too many questions were
not good in in the the
the elders of the city's view
and socrates was accused of corrupting
them making them question too many
things
which was not entirely true
another thing that he was accused of is
introducing
new gods to the city different gods and
the ones that athens believed in which
was also not quite true but the reason
for that accusation was that socrates
had or he said he had a special kind of
guardian spirit that would prevent him
from doing something or encountering
something bad
the guardian spirit would never tell him
what to do but he told him when he was
about to do something bad so prevent him
it's kind of like his conscience kind of
like your conscience would you know you
shouldn't be doing something
socrates had that and he talked about it
and people thought that he was
introducing a new god
and the other thing was that people
accused him of of making the weaker
argument the stronger that's kind of
hard to understand but that he would he
would try to persuade people
not of the truth but just persuade them
for its own sake
uh and he def he definitely never did
that but these were trumped up charges
people were just really jealous of
socrates and his success uh he had a lot
of fans i mean people would follow him
all around to listen to his questions
so he went off to jail
but his friends came every day to visit
him in jail
they talked
and danced
until he died
friends he used to say
have things in common
and his friends have been asking
questions ever since
now this picture
where is he obviously
in jail
all right do you think he's sad or happy
about it
tough question trick question
can you tell what do you
think well
he was sad that he got accused of the
things but he's happy because his
friends are visiting him and she can
still very good
excellent good and and when's the last
time we saw him dancing in the book
a little while ago right when he was in
there when he was at the symposium and
he was drinking with his friends and
eating and talking with his friends and
so even to the very last socrates does
what he always does he enjoys his
friends he asks questions and he dances
even in chains
and
of course there's his friend the flute
player the outlaws player playing away
anybody know how socrates did die in the
end you do yes poison
he had yes he drank poison hemlock um
and that was a way to execute people um
in ancient athens uh and there's a
description of this actually in plato's
dialogue the fido and um
and all his friends were around him when
he died and they were of course sad to
see him go
in fact one person was so sad that he
tried to prevent him from
accepting the death penalty that the
athenians passed against him by escaping
from prison and he said there's a whole
dialogue of plato that's about this
trying to convince socrates to to leave
prison and socrates says well that
wouldn't be right
i can't leave prison i can't disobey the
law
even if the law is wrong i still have to
obey the law
but we can try to persuade people to
change the law
but in my case this sentence has been
passed and i have to accept it and so he
refused to leave prison and um
and uh
and so died after drinking good julia
poison hemlock now this page i don't
know if you recognize anybody on this
page
an a for the day if somebody can
recognize at least one person on this
page
do you recognize this guy here
no
very good martin luther king jr right
that's probably the only one i'm going
to guess that you can recognize here
this is a page for the adults but you
can learn about each one on this other
page here how about this guy
yeah
excellent good that is indeed gandhi of
course it's a little it's a caricature
of gandhi isn't it made to look a little
funny kind of the same way socrates
looked a little funny
these people on this page are all people
who have been influenced by socrates and
there are many many more that wouldn't
fit on this page who have been
influenced by socrates and they they're
all different types of people
that's thomas jefferson he's a president
that's
that's martin luther king jr a great
civil rights leader and a baptist
minister
this lady here is called hannah arendt
she taught the university of chicago she
was a great woman philosopher and there
are many women philosophers and many
more still especially today than there
ever used to be
that one in the middle and the white
looks kind of like
[Applause]
this is a that is actually socrates
right there in the middle and he's
surrounded by his friends now i didn't
say something here that i should have
told you philosopher the meaning of the
word philosopher means friend of wisdom
and so so all these people as
philosophers are friends of wisdom and
so they're friends of socrates too
because socrates pursued wisdom with all
his art soul and life
that's friedrich nietzsche that's soren
kierkegaard that's bertrand russell
great mathematician and magician
this is uh ludwig wittgenstein crazy guy
looks like he just stuck his his finger
into an electrical socket his hair was
always sticking up like that yes
um
[Music]
and that's that's that guy's there is a
desiderius erasmus he was a a guy from
the renaissance who was very influenced
by by socrates
well good that's uh that's the story can
i answer any questions or did you have
any any thoughts um
about the about the book or socrates
that
i didn't answer
no okay well thank you for coming very
much
all right
yeah do you have any questions
christina you have a question i could
tell you have a question that your mind
is going to i can see it no no question
i can ask the first question
my first question is
when you were a little boy did you write
stories then uh
did i write stories i don't think they
were saved but i certainly wanted to
write stories i wanted to grow up and
write stories right and when you when
you did your writing
did you what types of things did you
write about
let's see that's a way back i have to
think about that
i was in the dragons i think ah
knights and dragons and things like
dragons and knights yeah yeah did you
ever write anything about animals
animals
i read books about animals
did you hear about dogs in particular
yeah because i grew up with a dog did
you ever write any stories about
adventures that you really had
like maybe visits that you made
somewhere or
you know what i did on my summer
vacation i think i had to do that as a
as an assignment once
you know and i bet you i'll bet you that
these kids also have written things
about
their experiences as well great and this
is a fabulous book i really did you all
like the book
yeah
did you enjoy taking the time
to have him explain things
me too you know i read this book before
he came and i learned so much more
having him be here so
um we'd love to thank you and we could
clap that would be great
thank you
one
great
question